the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
pieces flew across the boards at the
super bed rapid and blitz in warsaw
poland with plenty of points up for
grabs the full tour players scramble to
rack up as many wins as possible
legendary veteran vishwanathan anand is
still in the cat bird seat but hotly
pursued by duda caruana and aronian with
the americans hoping to climb in the
overall gct standings time is the enemy
who will be able to conquer the clock
day two of action-packed chess coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the
championship day here in warsaw poland
at the superbad rapid and blitz we've
had a fun event but in the end there can
only be one will it be one of the
challengers chasing the leader of
ichwanathanan or will the tiger of
madras reign supreme only time will tell
let's go to the studio and start today's
action with yasser peter and alejandro
[Music]
beautiful springtime views of the polish
capital as we welcome you to the final
day of the blitz today is day five of
this warsaw super bed rapid and blitz
the second stop on the 2022 grand chess
tour
good morning i'm peter swiddler and with
me is yasaseeravan peter it's wonderful
to be here with you and alejandro in
studio
seriously it's been great fun calling
all the action with you and aleandra it
has been and i'm i'm very happy to have
well not not have been here yet we're
still earlier still here yeah hello
everyone and thank you for joining us uh
this
anand has led from start till now
it's going to be an exciting sprint to
the finish can anyone catch him
peter please do the honors what's our
current standings
the situation at the top is uh is quite
clear
vichy has had a quiet day today uh
yesterday by his standards only scoring
five out of nine but he still leads by a
point and a half over over the rest of
the field he started the day with a one
point lead over richard rapport uh but
uh the the two stories of the day so to
speak are there tied for third really uh
where leonardo scored seven out of nine
which is a tremendous score and he has
actually been
soundly outscored by fabi
who who scored a barely believable eight
out of nine yesterday
catapulting him into this type of third
young chisholm dude had a very solid
outing yesterday isn't clear second and
richard raport and wesley saw can not be
counted out just yet with nine games of
blitz
incoming and our format uh peter the
format is a 10 player round robin we
played uh two of them already one in
rapid and one in blitz and one final
blitz round robin remaining time control
is five plus two they will play
uh colors reversed from the games
yesterday draw first continue not being
allowed whatsoever and uh the the rapid
double scoring is behind us we now get a
normal points for
for wins draws and losses and in case of
a playoff peter what is our format in
case of playoffs as you can see on your
screen if only two players die they play
a rapid match of ten plus five
uh and if it's if it's a tie of three
players uh or more uh then they play a
blitz round robin because obviously time
will be over in essence and the time
control needs to be shortened a blitz
round rubbing of five plus three
and if the if there's a still a tie for
first after all that uh an armageddon
game or games as we have seen
are possible uh with five minutes for
white four minutes for black uh you get
a two second increment starting from 61
to avoid the you know the flying pieces
and people playing bishop versus bishop
right and black obviously gets drawn uh
in an armageddon game wonderful good
morning alejandro how did we get here
good morning yasser good morning peter
certainly an exciting event we've had
two weeks of very intense chess we
started over there in bucharest we moved
on to warsaw and it's the final day of
these couple of tournaments in the grand
chess tour let's see where we split up
those grand chess tour points but let's
take a look at how we start in the final
day because we have some clear favorites
to take this tournament home vishy anand
as you mentioned starts with a one and a
half point lead over john shishof duda
the local hero but it's surging fabi and
surging lavon that have captivated our
attention let's start with levon he
comes out of a very nice tournament in
the american cup blitz section and
starts again with a very strong blitz
showing there in warsaw take a look at
that started with four out of four one
in round eight as well a couple of draws
sprinkled throughout his day and that
has kind of halted him to third place in
the event one and a half points behind
this man vishyanan was simply dominant
in the rapid started with five wins in a
row his splits a little more tapping he
did have a big result losing against
gabrielescu with the white pieces
certainly not keeping pace in the blitz
racking against the others but his rapid
was so dominant that he's still clearly
in the lead can he bring the tournament
home because this man fabiano carona we
don't know of him as a blitz specialist
well guess what that might change soon
because he was dominant in the american
blitz
american couplets he was dominant here
with an incredible eight out of nine
plus seven performance for fabulous five
he's won over a hundred blitz rating
points and let's see where that puts him
in the world take a look at how that's
shaking up the standings in the feeding
list at the very top hikaru nakamura
still the number one blitz player with
his massive 2850 but guess what number
two used to be magnus cross and he's got
him bumped out of that top three all the
way down to number four as levona ronyan
and fabiano carona are now occupying the
number two and number three spots
america occupying one two and three in
the blitz rankings well certainly
searching for us but let's take a look
at what the key pairings are for the day
to start the day because we have tons of
games ahead of us for that let's go to
our friends in warsaw anastasia and
christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to the final day of the
superbad rapidem blitz from location
here in warsaw poland to call all the
action and give you all the live updates
i am your host grand master christian
carrillo alongside woman grandmaster
anastasia carlos anastasia we've had a
lot of fun but it is time it is time to
crown a victor who do you have your eyes
on hello christian hello everyone lawson
lewis it's really a pleasure to be here
for the last day of the blitz
section and it's a little bit sad that
it's a final day but but still i'm
looking forward for this exciting rounds
and i will keep my eyes on still on
young christopheduda because he is on
the clear second place right now and he
didn't start so well yesterday
but later on he found his way and he won
three games in a row in the last three
rounds and today he plays once again
against tuition on the leader of the
tournament and actually he plays with
white pieces and i'm looking forward to
see how the game will finish
so kristen what about you that is such a
hotly contested start between vichy
anand and jan shishtav do the one player
that i'm having my eyes on has to be
levon aronian he started off yesterday's
rounds with four victories in the blitz
section he is just super happy to be
here to play chess to play rapid and
blitz i was chatting with him in the
skittles room in between games she's
just so enthusiastic about this
tournament and that happiness makes him
a very very dangerous man also if the
trend continues for him he started off
yesterday's rounds with the four point
deficits compared to vishyanan right now
we're starting the final day with only a
two point deficit if he maintains the
pace he's going to be able to
potentially catch with the leader let's
see what's going to happen is going to
be a fun and exciting final day guys
back to you in the studio in st louis no
question about that anastasia and
christian we are expecting a fabulous
sprint to the finish but let's start
with round one pairings peter let's take
a look at those uh
as always plenty plenty to look forward
to the game between our numbers one and
two uh in the cross table obviously the
central game of the round would do the
having the white pieces against bishop
but
uh richard rapport against uh caruana
there gotta be a backup yeah also a
tremendously important game for the
standings and then we also have uh radek
wajashek with white against wesley uh
the all ukrainian duel between anton
korobov and kiroshvchenko and levon is
playing white against gabriel esco
glasgow had his first i would say proper
good day on the tour yesterday he bit
vishy uh was completely winning against
wesley and just generally showed why why
he is so uh highly rated uh in in
romanian uh
uh chess uh chess circles but
still white white against gabriele is a
game that one will be looking looking
forward to i think absolutely the
players are all fighting hard why are
they fighting so hard uh peter because
they're prideful people
yes they are
but also there is some money at stake
there is as you can see uh on your
screen of 40k up top and going all the
way down to 7000 to
the eventual uh 10th place finisher and
there is gct points at stake with the
door progressing further and further
those become those become more and more
relevant
and you get more gcc points if you win
the tournament outright without tie
breaks which is what that 12-13 means
and there you see a beautiful view of
the stage
area as the players have those really
wonderful gamer chairs
uh and the round is about to start
as there you see e4 and away we go yeah
a petrov uh a petrov in the dudan game
uh
vichy has been she has been playing the
petrov uh consistently for a very very
long time five won a very
interesting game against him yesterday
but that was a different a different
better of not
not
third d4 this line has become quite
topical recently but yeah i've always
kind of
doubted it it does anything for white
but people clearly
people clearly feel that you know it's
at the very least leads to
unclear
unclear sharp positions which is what
something that you know do the ones out
of the opening here
g7 g6 came very very early i assume this
is all theory yeah still still clearly
uh
theory even though um
bishop e2 perhaps a slightly rarer move
even though i see on your screen that
yes uh there is at least one very high
profile game that reached this position
uh carrick and tapalov discussed this
at some point the plans for for the for
the sides are quite a clear cut black
has a very nice e6 square for for that
knight on c5 eventually and maybe even
the e4 square uh if if it becomes
available so you i think you keep it on
c5 for the time being
you probably fear the bishop's
development yeah you you probably also
would like
ideally to play bishop g7 castles in f7
f6
oh if you get if you get if you get time
for all of that he goes bishop e7
bishop e7 you play g7 g6 and then you
put your bishop on the east well g6 was
not really about the fianchetto it was
to to stop a four or five first and
foremost yeah i'm a bit surprised but i
guess supporting the knight on c5 has
its own value
uh
with the bishop on g7 this movie hp3
that we have just seen on our screen
would have actually attacked something
here it's just a developing move you can
play f6 here if you want to but that
uh yeah i think 96 is more logical you
can you can postpone playing f6 for the
time being the bishop on c8 is a bit sad
true right now
sometimes you can maybe
imagine going knight g7 but i prefer i
would prefer keeping it on
keeping it on e6 c3 played
i am somebody who is compulsively at
least looking at the move c2 and c4 in
these types of structures but uh and
christoph clearly disagrees and i think
he is right i think c4 would have given
uh vichy a kind of a clear target as to
how to equalize
a bishop c5 an invitation of course to
trade are you surprised i am i was going
to say i'm not i'm i'm not sure i
understand why this trade is so
beneficial but i think it's just that
the bishop on mission 2.3 is so uh well
placed that you just kind of need to get
rid of it maybe it was a full plug
to get our queen uh into the game queen
b6 but and uh i still find the move
surprising
regardless i mean now knight d4
uh f4 f5 on white's agenda f7 f6 i think
this was
timely yeah if you if you wait too long
f4 f5 is simply going to be absolutely
yellow king h1 played very quickly and
now the bishop c5 was actually hanging
because bishop takes e3 would not have
been a check meaning that knight 66
becomes a threat vicious of course
doesn't blunder that goes bishop b6
putting it on defended square
looks like black is okay to my eyes
because you you get to challenge the
pawn on e5 white hasn't really achieved
very much you also get to simplify along
the air file now
i would just take on e5 take on f1 go
queen e7 bishop d7 i think black is
completely fine
we already have
we have a completed game that's a
surprise as wesley so with the black
pieces
i think because of the king positions
it's yeah it's it's it's it's clearly a
draw yeah yeah i i don't yeah something
really really dramatic needs to happen
for the first game to not to finish in a
draw in this time frame um
and by the way we do have queen f3 uh
kind of just
intimating that queen g3 and bishop d3
might be on white's agenda after all
there aren't that many pieces around the
black king absolutely but
you mentioned
is the other way to treat this yeah
because i like that you take away some
squares and you want to play rook fade
uh the way to try to you know quote
unquote punish it would be to take on e6
b6 and play rook f1 stopping rook f8
from happening all together
but what about an inter meso but i think
we should be six rook fade for instance
is possible right that's the
intervention i'm worried about yeah
otherwise if you could do this then even
this position honestly i'm not that
foreign exactly i don't know i don't
think i think vish is just fine the
question is whether we wish we should be
better wow i think that's the uh that's
the question i'm trying to answer here i
very much like his position i think the
ball in e5 is much much likelier to be a
weakness than to be
a strong strength for white yeah
definitely white is missing the fact
that his rook on a1 is not in the game
you'd love to be able to play move like
queen f6 and make a pretense that you've
got some kind of initiative but even if
it's not true queen g queen h4 is just a
plain very very nice decision yeah
bishop v6 uh sorry takes stakes and ruka
fun immediately played by baidu i think
that's very sensible
uh black and i think pretty much
instantly equalized by taking on e3 and
playing rook f8
the question is whether there is
anything a7 queen e1 queen one queen g1
queen
yeah we're not losing a pawn but the
question is
i mean white clearly isn't worse there
no so
the ship will now consider if you can
play for a win here somehow
you can play queen g4 but once again if
if all we're looking for is a better
version of trading on e3 and trading on
a fade
we're still not really playing for a win
so you might as well just take the
comfortable equality
i'm guessing the the way to play for a
win bishop e3 by the way yeah i think i
think he's just going to go for
something along the lines of what we
described
but spawning rook cafe you can play b6
here i guess but why are we promoting
rook f6 yeah yeah
yeah no reason to allow white the
opportunity to play rook f6 rook f8 as
you said very very comfortable equality
and uh
we may be switching to another game as
this one looks very very bland to me uh
alejandro
alejandro what uh what have you been
following uh we can switch if you guys
want to the favi game between uh richard
and fabi we have a position that's
really crazy because you see the black
is actually down the exchange you count
the rooks uh black is on the exchange
but take a look at the white piece the
queen side they're not great so fiery's
got a couple of temp he can play knight
e5 he can play f4 at some point look at
the diagonal this bishop is kind of dead
but at some point it will come out
through b1 so
fabi's got an initiative against richard
right now
the question is what can he do in the
next couple of moves while white's
pieces come out of the background
sleeping yeah well i love what you're
pointing out moves like knight e5
not h3 was a very clever move though it
needs to be on f4 it needs to stop a 504
play for black it was a very very clever
clever decision there by richard
retreating sort of before it got kicked
away from g5 because it absolutely needs
to be on f4 as early as possible
um
i'm guessing the idea of 95 is to play
perhaps uh if you if white goes neither
four here
we can go knight g3 knight g3 f4 maybe
yeah maybe i think
rook for bishop or even maybe c takes d3
but i don't want to revive the bishop
yeah yeah that bishop on eight i would
like that passer but i would also like
not to give you that bishop
and now just bishop d6 and uh you know
this looks like great great initiative
yeah this looks this looks fantastic
yeah let me just refresh my board here
too uh but something else happened in
the game yeah he uh after 95 he went gc
bc and then knight four which is a
clever yeah i think specifically because
of the line we were showing it's a very
it's a very good choice
by the way what's the clock times yeah
we're being told five five is playing on
40 seconds against uh two two and a half
for for rickard but wow yeah he has a
very nice you know dominant set of
pieces
right
knight takes g5 has already been played
does this work how does this work how
does that just rocker five i guess
yeah and everything is hanging i mean
i'm sure when fabi went g5 and knight e4
he he thought he had everything
protected if you give if you give black
an additional tempo to play bishop g6
and then perhaps a five of four
black is kind of winning yeah yeah in
that game yeah but now knight takes g5
as you can see from the pause from the
pause even richard hasn't really
calculated this to the end he just
kind of hoped he knew he had to take on
g5 because his position was going to get
completely blown apart if he didn't i
guess the idea is whichever way you take
on f5 we have queen e7 that's the only
way i could find to protect our stuff
but it might be enough right well yeah i
wanted to go rook takes f5 queen e7 rook
f1 knight e4 i'm assuming
and then something like bishop b1 yeah
and and we play and we play but at least
black has protected all of all of the
stuff in the center which at first like
i couldn't see how you're gummied up
because i know
i know but there's no immediate threat
so it's uh we're expecting rook takes f5
and rook f1 and it's obviously good news
for fabi that
is thinking here yeah which means that
there and he has done rook takes f5
by the way um i'm being told
yeah we miss evaluated that end game in
the dude in the do the game and uh young
stuff is now significantly better
against the issue but this is a much
more interesting mess that we're
watching yeah rook five we need to stop
switching boys yeah rook five was met by
a
different choice here uh back to e4 i
don't know
i like that yeah if i be allowed uh rook
rook takes e5 and uh there is a very
beautiful knight on e4 and control over
the f file he has plenty of play here
actually i actually think that this is
maybe very interesting we can go rook f2
we can go queen g4 first yeah like three
questions
the question is how do i meet queen h6
um white needs to play queen h6 and hope
that at least postpones the the bad
things that are happening on the other
side of the board made in one is a good
threat meanwhile duda did defeat vichy
ana wow
[Music]
it's a half a point lead
for vichy only yeah and we'll stay with
this one absolutely we have to stay with
this one three encouraging queenie two
yeah and one blade
um i really like that queen h6 idea but
this is really
a different approach completely i don't
like this seizing the defensive
by
um
by richard good morning st louis
yeah uh black clearly has you know
plentiful compensation for for the one
point that we are now behind bishop
is just very very worried that white
might be lost yeah yeah it looks pretty
bad right
h4 you need to play a five like a four
b5 and like create something some kind
of destruction otherwise what's the
knight g3 and bishop g king h2
no he goes knight g5 with exactly the
same idea of bishop b4 and yeah you have
to go king hooking g3 here as well like
if the king doesn't run it will it will
legitimately just get mated but fabi
does the other thing he takes uh he
takes the bishop away from the g4 square
and now we can go bish before bishop
before looking and start pushing the c
pawn you can also include king of seven
king seven king of six just so that you
control the
uh the king on g3 a little bit better
check this out d3 interesting
interesting yeah and take stakes
yeah the bishop is just very very dead
on a2 this is like a low-key
oppositional masterpiece there by
um by fabie king four you can even go
king of six i wonder why he like he it
looked like he was he's very very happy
to threaten rook a5
that should be over gamer okay and then
the c pawn runs yeah he's gone bishop
sits uh i don't really understand yeah
one actually drew
actually drew
uh against governor lesko he was
crushing i i really don't understand
that particular
little maneuver he's still probably
winning but yeah just go rook five yeah
c4 this is what he doesn't like
bishop takes c4 he did not miss it he
just didn't want to allow bishop takes
c4 very clever by fabi actually okay
he's just going to play c c 2 and then
yeah i think he is back to being winning
and he is also not behind
anymore now he's threatening rook a5
under even
better yeah
would win the game immediately
okay
yeah i mean it doesn't matter okay five
come on come on yeah there you go and
rook takes day two
what a brilliant game it's time tomorrow
what a brilliant game by fabi and we
have one remaining game i think we do
korrabov and chefchaenko
is completely winning yeah as long as he
is not on one second here this this game
will be over very soon in grenade king
h2 you give him eight yeah it's just
just made on h6 he's also head on the
clock he just resigned
wow and time yeah and we have a we have
a half a point ball game
that's incredible i knew it was going to
be a sprint to the finish guys i didn't
realize it was going to tighten up so
far
being clear third firing clear third a
point of away from vision
wow what a tournament we have in our
hands wow
that is amazing and fabi's surging
through the standings even further
beating richard i love the compensation
that he got in this game it looked like
a classical game at some point
i believe around
because i don't know if he blundered the
exchange or not it was in this position
that he played the move c4
this was a wild position they had the
knights here ready to hop on to e6
that's kind of clear and this bishop is
actually pretty powerful in the diagonal
so if avi said
no more bishop for you
c4 it does give up an exchange though
because knight f e6 traps this rook on a
fade and after the move bishop h5 knight
takes that fade as a tempo so you don't
have time to take my queen i'll take
your queen and you end up losing more
material so favi took on a fade but the
evaluation is very unclear here because
this bishop is very powerful this bishop
is septic and eventually black actually
got hold of this important e4 square and
got tremendous compensation throughout
the game great start there for fabiano
caruana richard keeps falling apart he
was the one that ended the rapid portion
on in second place but now he's way way
below that wow and just to pick up what
happened in the vichy and non-game
because really we were thinking peter
that the move rook f8 for some reason
for some reason we completely
completely ignored the fact that you can
take on a7 without taking on f8 exactly
21 is now no longer a check
meaning that white gets to pick up the
opponent b7 with check and then defend
against and that's all the difference in
the world and that's all that uh duda
needed because
there's two points
up for not very much exactly and the way
he went
nice nice victory
and let's check in with warsaw let's do
that
thank you guys well actually i was uh
having my eyes on this game between
levon aronian and gavrielasko and this
was just a hectic game let's see what
happened after e3 early in the opening
we have knight to c6 knight to f3 this
almost looks like some sort of a trans
position into a car or con now c4
surprised cavalry lascu he actually
spent one minute at this point to play
the simple move e6 and after c5 bishop
to g4 queen uh knight bd to g6 that was
a mistake queen to b3 bishop to f3 a
huge mistake allowing white to gain a
decisive advantage immediately after
queen takes b7 knight to d4 and now
white just simply has a lot upon on c7
first of all a king on e7 and that's a
big big problem but check what happened
later on in the game so white was
completely winning throughout this game
and then we got to this point knight to
d4 loses some of the advantage but after
this move rook to e4 rook to e1 queen to
g4 check this out rook to a8 bishop to
f8 huge blunder queen to f5 just simply
forgetting about the knight on d4 this
changes the pace of this game now is
black who is completely winning queen
takes the four queen to see a queen to
before defending the bishop on f8 and
another big blunder by black rook to e8
allowing a draw after rook takes c8
queen takes f6 and now black has to be
forced to give perpetual with queen h5
queen to d1 quite a crazy game this one
anastasia what were you having in your
eyes oh it finished in the draw at the
end yes i was checking the game between
two ukrainians um anton korobov played
against uh kyriel shivchenko actually it
was i think it was a very important game
for anton who told me yesterday that um
losing in the first round uh didn't make
him feel happy yesterday so he for sure
he was trying to get to the the revenge
and they went for this benign variation
with g5 some old line um which probably
both of them knew until a certain point
even though shuchenko spent more time
than his opponent and here let's say the
theory goes until this point and after
bishop street normally people were
playing something like rook before
before yeah so after rd5 white got i
think quite comfortable position even
though after a few moves they exchanged
one of the bishops so why didn't have
any more the pair of the bishops and the
game just continued you know position
with this deep um pawn um very strong
one at the same time black is doing
quite well yes it seems like fine black
we're doing fine and actually you know
that in the endings i mean in blitz
games sometimes knight is better than
the bishop right we know this is a funny
quote from uh lester and hoard but
black didn't manage to prove it because
white found the way how to kick the
knight very quickly and the position
still remained quite balanced and here i
don't know
suddenly um anton started to maneuver
with his queen and um
right now there was a problem so that's
why black had to kick out this queen and
then he somehow managed to win this pawn
on a5 i mean after a few moves and now
we just can see that white has a pawn up
and he just wants to exchange everything
and go for the ending winning ending and
after a couple of moves
like now again he wants to take on a six
and uh
just to have a good great position after
that so we can see that now it was
another blunder by kill and after bishop
said okay just the white has more
material i think it's a really important
victory for anton corbin maybe he will
find his way today it was really sad to
see him yesterday losing basically
everything huge victory for him and a
lot of things have changed at the top
with duda beating vishwanathan
and caruana winning against rapport that
was just an insane round guys back to
you in the studio thank you and let's
see those changes peter yeah and uh
after the first round of uh of blitz
today we have a half a point lead for
vichy yeah it's becoming closer and
closer close uh
young beating beating vichy gets to
within that half a point uh fabi winning
a very very important head-to-head
against richard rapport uh further half
a point behind then levon 17 and a half
and a bit of a gap opening up between
the top four and exactly and the players
tied for fifth on 16 and a half points
huge victory can't be overstated by duda
i mean what does that do for his chances
is fantastic yeah i mean
starting a day like this should be apart
from sort of the material factors there
you know getting getting the gap close
down to half a point right you also feel
you know feel better you you feel that
you know the day has started properly
and right he was a very well played game
as well
yeah i think i think he'll be very happy
with with this overall
no question about it and uh from warsaw
we have christian with a very special
guest
we are here with michael kolarkowski the
spokesperson of the grand chester
michael welcome back to the show now
tell us your first impressions about
poland and how the tournament went from
your perspective well poland all
together is a great country and warsaw
is a capital beautiful weather beautiful
venue and
excellent tournament especially with the
veteran vichy anand
showing young players
what what it is to play uh a real cheers
when you're over 50. so we will see
whether he will be able to stay on his
course and win all together but
we we understand
that uh fabiana livone
and richard obviously want
to
to recapture
this lead as well as
home
uh
trophy
duda who wants to
show that he is the real contender for
the first place not to mention that all
of the above players
uh
except anand
are going to play one month from now at
the candidates tournament so it's
certainly sort of a showcase for them
uh before the tournament and i believe
this is the last tournament that they
played together before candidates
tournament for the world championship
cycle definitely a beautiful preview of
those upcoming matches now talk to us a
bit about this incredible partnership
between the granchester the saint louis
just club and the super beth foundation
well i would say that it's perfect match
between two non-profit organizations
saint louis chess club and superbed
foundation
that basically put synergy
and mission to promote cheers worldwide
and not only among elite players but
among youngsters as well and as you
could see
besides uh
this tournament in
i mean grandchild's tour tournament uh
classical tournament in bucharest rapid
blitz and warsaw we conducted several
side events and it brought so many
youngsters
and attention to
tournament
not only chess players but mainstream
and mainstream media
another big event is coming after this
one in croatia next month tell us a bit
about that what are you expecting to see
in that tournament
actually it would be very interesting
tournament because it
it would take place
upon conclusion of the candidates
tournament so we will know
who actually is going to be a challenger
for the world championship
cycle for the world championship title
and
breaking news
that world champion
reigning champion magnus carlson is
going to participate in zagreb as a wild
card excellent and you told me that
there might be even more uh breaking
news is that correct and what can you
tell us about that yes in addition to
that magnus carlsen will participate
at the last
stage of the grand chess tour and
classical event sinful cup so it would
be probably not probably definitely the
strongest tournament of this year
michael this is amazing news thank you
very much for breaking it for all of us
here in the studio thank you very much
and we'll see you in croatia
definitely you heard it here first
magnus carson will be playing both in
croatia and at the same field cup in st
louis
thank you christian chess players are in
love
with the grand chess tour peter yeah
this is definitely good news you you you
want to have magnus participating
it's uh it's always uh it attracts
additional attention gct is a very very
strong series as it is but with the
participation of
the world champion in the events it
obviously uh you know
acquires an additional luster gravitas
yes and let's take a look at the
pairings as we go into this round 11
second blitz game
of the day peter uh yeah there we have
uh at the top there uh kerosefchenko who
started by losing his first game here
against gabrielesco vichy plays against
anton korobov who is on a bit of a
bit of a rollercoaster winning winning
one game in a row is very important i'm
not even kidding it really is it really
is
wesley is white against duda uh phi b is
white against wojteshek and then we have
the uh richard rapport against the one
our onion game who's our marquee
match-up peter do the honors uh you have
to choose i think between the game
between wesley and dude and the uh
rapport iranian game uh wesley duda in
terms of standings i think is slightly
higher profile but dropout are onion
probably more chaotic so
uh it's a it's a toss-up i
okay split split the split the fence
sitter uh alejandro rockwood aronian
there you go i'm i'm happy with this
everybody's happy everybody's happy
richard
now richard though he starts the today
with two whites but he's just gone down
in flames
uh to fabiano in an almost flawless
example of how you play blitz by fabi
very very nicely uh done by fabi and
richard also notably uh went all for
three yesterday he started by losing the
first three so
seems to
be a kind of a repeating story uh
obviously only one game uh
well played so far but
and for levon get into his mindset i
mean he starts the day he's got white
he's got up against one of the lowest if
not the lowest it's something he had
plus seven on the board it's completely
winning position yeah inside of a dozen
moves this is this is what will hurt
yeah he will know that he
he missed a major major opportunity
opportunity he could be sitting at 18
and only a point behind but just as
equally he could have lost the game he
was
blundered
but still i'm pretty sure he will be
more more focused on on the fact that he
was completely not now we see why the
game that richie is going to play
against duda is so critical richard
having the white pieces if he can clip
dude for a whole point you you will yeah
he will definitely
storm back into into the conversation
there and yeah there's still plenty of
rounds to play of course games yeah for
both wesley and rickard here they they
need to start winning games
now
if
jump in what caught your attention in
this round what was rickard's form is
what worries me because he had mentioned
that warsaw had been a difficult venue
for him in the blitz that he played last
of course that was the world
championship in warsaw in december where
he lost a ton of rating there's no other
way to put it okay i think he came to
the show and said he lost something
along
160 that's bad that's bad
and i feel that when he doesn't feel at
home
he starts tumbling and there's something
in the psyche that's telling him blitz
warsaw not combining and i just don't
feel that he's gaining this traction the
attraction that he gained in the rapid
for example
just kind of falling apart here in the
blitz yesterday he did it zero out of
three to start the day i don't want to
see him richard starting zero out of
three again no no
absolutely and blitz chess it's it's a
streaky it is it is very tricky yeah
it's very hard to explain
give it a crack i think i think it's
actually reasonably reasonably easy to
explain because blitz is you know the
the closest to sort of the pure
expression of your
of your chest skill
uh a lot of it depends on intuition you
just let your hand guide the pieces to
this and
when much of it is autopilot yes
[Music]
confidence and
you know your
your trust in your own instincts is a
huge huge part of uh doing well and when
you are doubting
every single decision you take you play
slower you play you play less
confidently and it it all compounds
itself so i think yeah in
with with specifically i think it's very
easy to understand why
why being in the right frame of mind or
feeling well about your play is
extremely important and why people go on
those streaks because it all it all
snowballs yes if you
it's about to say once again uh the two
fashion
icons
yes dueling shirts who comes out on top
on this one i'll give it to i'll give it
to levin in this particular i'm gonna go
with richie i kind of like the olive
green with the white
break the tie alejandro unlimited
breadsticks yes
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna have to go with
levons today
wow there's no accounting for that was
very objective
objective evaluation no accounting for
good taste i tell you the youth lives
today
and uh here is we're getting set uh
these early rounds are so key uh for
everything that you said and i think
that confidence is actually a huge part
of it all yeah blitz hinges so much on
you trusting on your trust in your hands
and for fabi his he can't be
any higher right now i mean he is just
sailing away why not attend yeah rickard
continues uh fooling around with all of
these bishops before against the guy
who's been fooling around with bishops
he also played it against fabi it's uh
you know that bishop on a2 there that
was a sicilian as well so exactly with
the bishop on c4 which i am very happy
to see dai after this tournament please
please
and now's the time to play d4 if you're
gonna play it yeah
let's go yeah i mean dragon you've
tricked
lavon into playing a dragon now
lavon is capable of playing anything
this is just
isn't queen b6 here okay no
yes yes no queen b6 is good here no yes
yes it's very playable i mean good is
maybe a longer statement but it's
definitely playable qb6 knight five can
be took knight seven king f8 there's
plenty of theory but it actually works
yeah wow but we're going for a main line
good old-school dragon not even the
knight takes g4 version yeah king b1
yeah i'm a bit
i mean h i've never properly studied
h4h5 lines i've always played king b1 in
that position but uh we heard clearly
yeah but it's very good look at this
i think i studied this when i was a
teenager
neither of them is a dragon player
that's what i'm saying what is happening
they're just spanking out all the most
topical theoretical moves as if this is
all part of the repertoire legitimately
thinking the one kind of misplaced uh
sort of replaced stage four as as
the go-to
and i think it's also a much wiser
choice in blitz because in particular i
mean if you if you've looked at this
recently sure go for it but but if you
haven't the positions you get after king
b1 are a lot
more humanly understandable because here
i think at some point you're just
supposed to like go a g4 hgf4 i hope
yeah and then and then like if you're if
you're another specialist in these lines
you're just
like yes you're you're you're you're
right you're you will you'll be making
blunders every move and just hoping that
your blunders are less less painful that
your opponent's blunders because your
opponent probably also doesn't know it
doesn't remember anything
so yeah stakes are unbelievably high if
you if you play the
uh the dragon this way but richie i
think very wisely sidesteps all of those
types of extremely forced variations
goes knight to
g4 b3
and so on so bishop e3
uh b5 before is prepared now when the
bishop is on g5 normally you've got
as your break
uh
with
this setup my feeling is black is more
than equalized he's kind of like
pass through equality
hasn't he
it's a it's still very playable for
white you can go bishop d4 before knight
d5 for instance like that would be an
ideal scenario i would suspect uh black
often includes z75 somewhere but it's
not prepared yet you can go a5 here and
just kind of
sit on that decision for one more move
anything to be said for e7 e6 just to
deny white the opportunity of playing
knight b5 i'm sure you're not going to
capture that yeah yeah probably not
probably not no no yeah i i can see that
i can see that um i don't think it's an
easy move to make because you generally
want to won that pawn on e7 for as long
as possible
if you do touch it it normally goes to
e5 but yeah i like it fighting for the
d5 square is a lavon
what's the role of the knight on e2
peter
what are you going to do with the knight
it stays there for now i think we can go
95 now it doesn't lose material and
since we're probably going to be going
to have to make that move anyway you
might as well do it you might as well do
it immediately um and then something
like bishop takes pawn takes i don't
know a5 let's just yeah toss it down
yeah if the ball was still on b2 i i
would probably be quite happy with this
with white but upon b3 uh lesser
but once again i think we just go g4
here and we say okay let's start the
race
in particular in a blitz game i think i
just go g4 here and i say i'll come on
i'm not really getting made any a file
just yet let's open up how do you like
your fate yeah let's let's gamble and
let's roll the dice roll the dice he's
still thinking bishop c6 he has not
played knight d5 what could be a
possible alternative well like idiot g4
no not with a bishop on c6 right it
doesn't feel right you can go right
the bishop yeah i'm curious what the
other movie even even is here
um
queenie
doesn't make it it would be a terrible
alternative that would just walk it
would have been a move if not very fire
yeah it would have been a movie would
have considered yeah so yeah
i'm just wondering what
would be rook e1 i don't know
so yeah take stakes and i'm guessing a5
although yeah seven is the choice
hinting at the knight takes d5 tactics
because in the end there after queen
takes d5 queen takes c2 will pick up the
knight on e2 so white has to spend the
tempo
uh
solely defying
their position somehow rook c1 is one
where rook h e one would be the other
right the knight steel doesn't really
want to go anywhere
neither four looks shaky although you
can play it here if you wanted to
i mean i like rook h1 e1 and i actually
think that's the best move but it does
give up g4 exactly right yeah i think uh
it's an achievement for black because
you no longer really have to calculate
those those positions with exactly with
g4 which is why i'm mentioning rook c1
but 61 queen b7 is actually quite very
awkward right how do you like this
how do you like these apples uh g4 right
away just go gee four straight you take
on d5 we take on just tell when we take
on h5 right yeah knight c3 check though
you trade stuff and it's okay it's fine
for black i think i agree another four
actually played yeah i was saying it's
kind of shaky because i i didn't really
like bishop h6 i thought bishop h6 might
be quite annoying here
um
but maybe maybe it isn't i don't know
first of all that's a great move i love
it yeah and it has been played instantly
i thought that that must have been the
idea from
allows immediate draw
but levon probably plays for a win here
right you can take on a four take on d5
and give a perpetual hero right
but i was afraid that if i didn't play
bishop e3 if i go g3 knight takes d5 is
yeah an embarrassment yeah oh and he has
he's got
immediately is unplayable if you take on
f4 and you take on d5 you'll allow a
four or five but black will once again
have an ic3 check in that position so i
think it's playable yeah and i think
here he goes
alejandro what do you got for us
well guys sorry to deviate here for a
second but this is an important one
vishyanan against anton korbov we have a
mess on the board count the rooks it's
definitely a vision that has more
material you have two rooks against one
one knight against the two bishops but
the position is hopeless
it's hopeless for white bishop e3
tactics are hanging this knight is just
off the board e5 is coming with queen g5
and bishop takes g4 huge attack here for
corbett on the
king side black is in full control in
this position the engine is actually
saying minus seven this would be a huge
result if vichy goes down
against anton korvo that would open the
tournament
for a lot of players to catch or even
potentially pass vichy in the coming
rounds wow wow a terrible start
we were talking about the importance of
starting well and yes
you immediately notice a huge difference
with yesterday for anton yeah having won
his game one he is now playing really
well against vichy
vishy is very very you know tricky to
pin down completely you still can't rule
out which is somehow escaping with this
but the position is lost yeah i mean
there's no there's no doubt about the
objective variation of the position
right now by the way uh going back to
the game of richard and actually just
recycling it just resigned it just uh
vishy
opening up the door to the competition
as levon has just snapped
upon
yeah and yeah
left seems to be completely winning uh
now because he yeah he took on d5 took
on the four i think that takes a four
may have been missed by
uh by richard and yeah black is now up
two pawns and also has the better
position pretty much so yeah but
i gotta say i i see this game as a a as
a a dueling bluff if you will both
players don't play the dragon if both
players decided to play the sharpest
lions everybody plays the dragon
everybody plays the dragon in spirit
nobody actually plays
this last sequence actually gave
her some some some hope because i think
uh uh
e4 yeah quincy one i think he forgot
queen juan existed or perhaps he wanted
to go rook eg8 queen g1 queen queen c3
queen takes f3 and now he realizes
allows rook takes g6 and white will have
at least a perpetual so i mean he's
still probably winning but he just
basically gave away a pawn for
for nothing how could he do that
sacrilege
and this time he used the sea rook he's
switching to like a technical when he no
longer is aiming to uh to win by by
uh by tactics he can even maybe go into
a rook ending which looks looks to be to
me to be completely winning like go rook
d1 queen e1 i like that and like very
much yeah and then just win this uh this
end game quite comfortably because we we
know that these uh this was a mistake i
think because now rook f1 wins the
opponent of three and that has to signal
the end of the game right
true uh rook f1 rook h1 either one
grab the one that's closest to the
coronation square he's gone rookie three
which is interesting and richie also
interestingly says i am not at all going
to protect anything i need my own
passion something to be said for king f8
and introducing the king into
independence yeah but it gets cut off by
the g file this is this is actually
somewhat in a blitz game a little bit
trickier than you would have liked with
black i think you just take on a three
and you go see five repeats
yeah you're just you just because you
have you have so many uh so many guys
running running on that look what he's
decided instead he's going with the
passive rook but he's also going with
the active king yeah
i don't like i don't mind this at all i
don't mind this i like this choice uh
yeah he just goes roxy five here gives
up
check check
yeah you can throw you can throw in ruby
five check it out if you think that good
culture a good culture if you think the
king is worse yeah a very very good
culture there by yesterday yeah rook d7
or k7 but then basically
uh the the huge majority yes on the king
side will become instantly decisive
pretty much and by the way with the king
on a3 lucky look you're just doing a
fall down
i got very much thought something by
yasser
um
it's a bit it's a bit tricky yeah and i
thought it was time for f6 and g5 and
just get them doggies moving
i think yeah he's still fine he's still
fine can you oh that's a clever movement
f1 is such a massive threat it's true
true true yeah yeah actually five
yeah yeah you're just helping black with
rookie four i think rook f1 yeah
there was no good choice yeah there was
no good choice
g5h4 i think goes
by the way we're not going to switch the
games but we've been told that two of
our uh
leading uh contenders for the crown are
in trouble fabi and duda both bobby's
dead
what a round i'd be alejandro jeez
that's incredible five is dead lost but
wesley is pushing against duda but that
one is still up in the air okay well
but for now i'm thinking it's isn't it
just time to get the show on the road f6
g5 i think even g5 hgh4 honestly
probably wins quite comfortably
yeah i actually calculated that and then
forgot about it
there we go f6 and uh
push them baby yeah they fine now we can
get our rook behind the pawn or
stabilized and then i realize that's not
actually true fabi is still getting
slaughtered there by by radic and what
is the times of this game in this one
yeah uh
rehard is down to five seconds left
still has half a minute
uh richard obviously not at all
interested in opening up additional
files so he doesn't take on g4 but yeah
this position has to be lost
yeah just go rook c8 through k8 and and
yeah a7 actually gets traded for f3 here
so yeah you're completely lost
so
where the triple pawns are actually
really strong
it's very curious to me that he hasn't
gone wrong eight rook seven one way and
one win is enough yeah one one is enough
yeah
oh
queen with check is there some crazy
stalemate nah he really doesn't know
guys we gotta switch to the dude game
yes we still have it because wesley's
about to resign wesley resigns against
duda oh no oh count them up count them
up big shake up at the standings let's
take a look at fabi versus ryder
goytachik because this one is also huge
can somebody finally put a stop to favi
and it looks like yes those are two
connected past pawns onto f5 two extra
yeah yeah extra connected fast phone
yeah why is he not what the
yeah he knows how to do this uh that's
not how i would have done it but okay
it's good enough
right is it why did you no you go
kingston you know
i also understand that but it's funny to
go what's excellent d6 what what oh no
no this works still it's still good
enough strange technique but it was good
enough good technique
some are leaders losing in this round
fabi going down finally in the blitz
vichy going down to korobov that wow has
opened up the gates for duda and for
lavon aronian but duda i believe is now
in clear first let's take a look at what
happened in his game because this was an
absolutely crazy crazy game here between
wesley saw and john shisht of duda duda
going for broke look at the way that he
handled the opening a soft english by
wesley was met with a huge expansion on
the king side by the polish hero just
not afraid of throwing down pawns i'm
gonna skip ahead a couple of moves a lot
of moves to see exactly what happened
with white going on the queen side black
going on the king side and wesley doing
it in a very strong manner putting in a
knight on c6 even at this point giving
up the knight just to be able to take
back with the pawn and establish a
majority but dude didn't care just left
his bishop hanging on d7 for a long long
time
the computer didn't like a lot of these
moves but we don't really care about
that and eventually we got to a position
around here
where white has the control over c6 but
black is starting to pretend
that there is some real counter play on
this side of the board and i think it
would have been quite wise to at some
point just push the pawn to h4
close down this side and focus on the
other even though the engines say this
would only be equal because black is
just holding on to the queen side
himself but instead wesley allowed both
sides to be open and around here this
move h takes g4 you see things haven't
changed that much here h64 h takes g4
white thought he could handle the h file
as well as black good not true because
it was black that found his way into
this position queen h1 king g6 rook h8
coming on the board as soon as i
defended with the move queen d8 or rook
h7 soon king f2 queen f6 one way of
defending a chad also eyeing the a1 rook
eyeing the entrance of the queen and you
can see how deadly this was in this
position after bishop f1 rook h2 bishop
g2 queen b2 check this is kind of ugly
queen is also picking up b5 wesley
getting ripped apart from both flanks
and this king on g6 absolutely safe
after rook c2 yes there are other wins
queen takes b5 is not the best but it's
good enough because in this position
black already has a very sizable
advantage has the two extra pawns knight
jumping in paul coming forward rook
takes c4 still is a mess after rook
queen takes on rook d6 it's not a draw
but rook d4 allows the game to finish
with this very pretty tactic knight
takes e3
to finish the game
yes
um
yeah so if you take on c5 you take on on
d1 rook takes g2 is also a thread and if
you take on e3 then queen a3 check no
good way of defending your third rank
because uh king f2 queen f3 check is the
way i think the game finished king takes
e3 queen a3 king f2 and queen f3 check
you have to trade queens bishop on g2
false at the end completely hopeless
endgame let's go to warsaw to see the
remaining games huge one here for dudas
we have a new leader over there in
poland
this tournament is getting absolutely
wild it was a madhouse in the game
between caruana and voytashek and you
guys were saying uh caruana is winning
no caruana is losing no carware is
winning again and then he was losing
it's exactly what happened starting off
from somewhere around here so after g3 a
slow build up white is going to try to
make use of the two bishops potentially
open things up at some point with the
move effort the same is going to happen
from the blacks perspective because
black is going to try to go g6 and then
f5 typical king's indium stuff so let's
see what happened queen to e2 h6 it's a
king's indiana structure but you don't
have the dark square bishop as black so
you have to be careful about that knight
to d2 at this point black could have
played the move f5 and i think this was
a crucial moment for voitasha to try to
take over the initiative he did not play
that he decided to go bishop to d7 quite
timid approach by the pole uh knight to
e7 f4 white opens up things black goes
queen to a5 bishop to c2 and check this
out so we got all the way to this
position absolutely after some crazy
complications of course the critical
idea in this position after knight takes
g3 is that you cannot take with the
queen because rook g5 is going to come
and you're going to
lose the queen it's going to be trapped
so
immediately after knight takes g3
fabiano
after a
15 second start took on f6 found the
right approach now the idea of behind
taking on f6 is that after you take on
f6 i'm going to go knight to b3
targeting the queen first and more
importantly opening up the bishop on c1
so now once you get the queen back to a6
i'm going to be able to take the knight
on g3 rook g5 doesn't work anymore
because of bishop takes g5 and you can
resign so you have to go uh king to h7
and that creates another threat and that
is the other who coming from aa to g8 to
trap the queen now how do you defend
against that king to h to the wrong side
what he was supposed to do was king to f
to go to the other side so that you
don't have to worry about any sorts of
checkmate threats after rook takes h5 so
the bishop on d1 for example if you take
on c4 i can just simply go knight to d2
and the bishop on the one is going to be
free to roam around i can go bishop to
e2 later on and just make use of my
extra material instead of that he played
the move king to h2 and now the game
became completely wild c4 double uh
double question mark rook to g8 queen to
f4 queen to a4 double question mark sure
it is white who is winning right now no
no no sorry it is black who is winning
up right now after bishop to f3 bishop
to ca white again who is winning it was
just a complete mad house check this out
rook to j rook to g5 bishop to d2 queen
to d7 threatening checkmate on h3 queen
to h4
and we got this position i think this is
where you guys caught up with this game
and after this fabiano did not stand the
chance to stop black spawn and
unfortunately for him had to uh lose the
first game of this tournament for him
anastasia what a crazy game
okay this was completely white yes yes
so i was uh checking more quiet game
let's say after french development i
mean the french defense was explained
between the two youngsters yes the
youngsters we're trying to find out
who's the best one today and
this is some theory and
you you can see that white gave up the
pawn for some kind of compensation for a
long-term initiative so he's trying to
use the fact that development of black
is not so great so i think kirill played
actually quite well until a certain
point actually it was interesting knight
g5 what would happen after h6 i was
wondering will he be able to take on f7
it seemed to me perhaps
maybe h5 i was not sure what's going on
but i mean okay
definitely i mean there were many
different options here for wyatt and for
black and let's say it was interesting
that here black decided not to go full
on castling probably he was afraid of
some b4 later the sb5 we would see the
opposite color opposite side castling
position so he decided actually to keep
his king on the other side but he didn't
do again he couldn't do the short
casting bishop he was coming so after it
was interesting so the king was moving
towards
the king's side and actually the rook
was stuck on that shade and i just would
like to mention that white was doing
well i mean increasing his initiative
and they were just you know
maneuvering around until i would like
this to go to this moment all go wrong
for yes young ukrainian player yeah so i
think somewhere here i mean at the
moment when finally this rook went out
and you know this situation went finally
once it looks good yes it still looks
good dominating right this bishop on
this six this one even though black has
this pawn on a file still white has
quite good initiative and threats and
always you can combine those so and at
this moment finally rook came to see it
yes i mean finally it's here but still
bishop before
yeah bishop f4 was played g4 very
aggressive move of course white is
trying to do something with this king
and then of course now he had to
understand that he there are some mutual
threats from the from the black side and
he made this crucial mistake yes
yes and then the queen no longer
controls the c1 square exactly yes i
think this was a problem and he didn't
have much time at that moment of course
and six seconds yeah he could have taken
this rook for example and play this
ending which um is not really dangerous
this pawn is not so dangerous because
always white has some threats here for
example queen c8 it takes on h5 and like
sounds like quincy two black should play
to keep you know this kingside safe so
which was still not so easy also for
black and what happened okay i just
would like to show you the end let's say
let's come back here what happened is
simply that black came to the last rank
and first rank until just checkmated
poor white skin repeat it once yes and
to make sure that has got two seconds
and then okay it's just um
i mean you can see all those threats
discovered attack and just collapsing
coming a huge victory a huge victory for
the young romanian yes actually he
started quite well with one with one and
a half right one and a half out of two
but of course the big story of the round
is that vichyanan is no longer the
leader of the event duda is the new top
dog guys back to you you did tell us for
the first time basically in the vision
has been leading from round one round
one from five to five five out of five
in the rapids and this is round twenty
if we count the yes if we count the rep
this is around 20. so he's led for 19
rounds straight and has finally been
overtaken by youngster of duda uh yeah
very uh unusual
at the top yeah yeah it's it's all very
very tight even though uh wesley and
rickard are now in trouble in terms of
challenging for let's say the top three
finish uh speaking of which uh what
about the pairings then yeah the
pairings for round three of today's uh
rapid around robin is vishy is playing
gabrielescu who he famously uh lost to
yesterday with the white pieces uh levon
is white against shivchenko kore above
plays against wesley uh duda is white
against uh
yeah that has to be the game we're
watching and raleigh who has just beaten
fabi is uh playing against richard wow
and of course for those of you who want
to know what's going to happen well we
have today in chess coming up also after
this event that will be the candidate's
full coverage uh from june 17th to july
5th join us here in studio in st louis
for our coverage for d22 candidates
absolutely for a given different
definition of us us
for a given division
we're in us yes territory uh i just
wanted to point out this i i just
thought this was a stunning finish in
the game of fabi and uh reddick after
this move queen a4 i i mean it's crazy
right i looked up exactly at that moment
and i thought what a beautiful move
queen a for hitting the bishop
go ahead and take my queen except you
look at this bishop on c1 and you think
to yourself
if i could do it that would be checkmate
myself he could have played knight f1
and i wonder i wonder if he saw i wonder
if he saw quincy to check and thought he
was losing but you can ignore it again
[Laughter]
what an amusing finish that was i'm just
i just had to share that uh yeah
appreciation to anastasia and
um christian for pointing out the game
and that helter skelter chaotic game i
just thought that was a nice that was
sort of a proper blitz game right lot a
lot of ideas a lot of good tactics
calculated but also a lot of tactics
missed yeah you you do get games like
this very often and between strong
players
i have to give anastasia some credit she
picked duda and she yeah she's stuck
with her pick throughout yes she's being
rewarded for her loyalty we were not
allowed to switch her
besides the obvious yeah
uh alejandro what do you think about
this uh shake up at the top what a what
a great second round five black
victories to just
shake up the standings right because
vichy's no longer the leader favi got
passed by levon and it seems that the
story of wesley and richard we finally
say goodbye to those scopes three points
off the lead with eight seven rounds to
go
yeah that's just too much of a
difference right but duda local hero
playing blitz properly now he has got
what is this his fifth win in a row yes
he finished yesterday with three wins in
a row i called it castling but i meant
it in reverse castles is three zeros in
a row but he got the three pins yes
he's building a fence right and there we
have a view of the stage a very very
beautiful beautiful venue this is the
the theater inside the polish museum of
the history of polish jews uh in in
warsaw uh obviously uh
very very uh nice and i do have to say
that playing in a venue like this kind
of yes it lifts your game an additional
two percent somewhere right it does give
you does give you a bit of a boost when
you have to when you play on a stage
like this and it it feels like
i always felt whenever i was on a stage
that's
really really gorgeous and probably one
of the best stages i've ever played in
was actually in belgrade
it was and the audience in the old
yugoslavia yeah boy did they know their
chats
and now that we have a slight pause here
we've had this conversation and there
was also uh one of the arbiters of the
granchester uh shout out to david cedric
yeah also participated in that in that
conversation via email right we were
talking about applause during games and
apparently uh there's also a review i
think of the queen's gambit which
doubted this ever happens right at the
chess tournament and my story on this
topic is
i was playing in garyvayne in 96 prior
to the olympiad in the area when i i
played a tournament in the area
uh that same year and in the last round
i was playing against the local heroes
putin who
i'm sure you know very well played many
times yeah he is a piece of cold figure
in armenian church and very very well
supported
and i wasn't really in the running for
much but he was in the running i think
for for the first place and
at some point
we were playing some kind of a king's
indian attack and uh i left the pawn on
d3 on praise and he could take it with
the knight but the knight would then get
captured on d3 because it had no moves
but he could do it and then like collect
my entire queen side for the for the
piece like the black would have this
feast of pawns on the green side
marching down the board but it would be
at the price of the piece and he thought
for a bit
and took on d3
and i didn't even play rook d1 yet
and the entire auditorium erupted in
applause
this happened to me i'm not lying about
this
guys
and and
honestly it's kind of a strange feeling
because the game is nowhere near over
you you're trying to think about your
move this is really kind of distracting
a little bit but also you feel like you
know you're in a picture yeah people
people watching clearly understand
what's happening because you know i
haven't even won the piece yet
and they know it's a sacrifice they know
the game will become much sharper yeah
and they're just loving it and yeah i
love it nice story as play is underway
this is this uh early bishop b4
uh knight d5 variation that was kind of
popular in the 90s i
never really understood why it went out
of fashion that was why michael marin in
his book on the english suggested g3 on
move two just to sidestep this uh bishop
among other things yeah and it's it's
kind of weird because black is basic
basically playing the bishop b5 sicilian
a full tempo down and it's still quite
good
it's still quite the rossolimo a full
tempo down and uh yeah the knight on e7
that's still very playable i guess he
wants to put the other knight to f6 yeah
i was also a bit surprised we we're not
taking with the queen there but right i
think you're right the other one needs
to be placed somewhere and it goes d7 f6
now f2 f4 pretty funky looking french
alejandro yeah ef ef shocks me here
honestly like i'm i don't know e f yeah
this is challenging lots of the things i
know about chess yeah
i am kind of giving up here i have no
idea what's going on anymore and i like
this for white a great deal suddenly
right well because the white why was it
there right i i like this for white a
great great deal i mean 97 out of six
yes i understand and he's done it yeah
actually this is
i thought we were in time to push e3 4
but if we're not in time to push e3 4
this is playable for black this is not
that bad i still pick white here but
uh in particular if we find a way to get
the knight away from e7 because
currently quincy 2 is a very clever move
yeah because we would very much like to
play something like knight g6 27 knight
e4
and keeping you honest on the f5 pawn
yeah quinn quincy is a clever movie now
we go b3 bishop b2 rook a1 we hope maybe
at some point to push d4 d5 if black
plays 65 the bishop will go to a3 and
not to b2
knight e4
symptom i think black's position just
get rid of the pawn but
i think this is clear i think this is
clear i think that's a good rule and
also we i think we ignore it with white
yeah you just uh something like the
three anyway has played b3 already yeah
we don't care we we definitely don't
take straight away we might take later
and now taking actually would lose the
queen if we take twice now kind of a
curious situation where the queen on e4
actually has no squares and gets picked
up by bishop five
there for black i mean daylight robbery
yeah obviously not happening just a cute
variation
it goes to show you why he played knight
e4 you were mentioning the knight on e7
yeah this is the setup yeah this is the
setup you want and oops sorry i'm i'm
warming to due to black's position
honestly this is now very acceptable we
won bishop d7 rook a8 i still don't know
exactly what the
i want to get rid of the knight he's
played that yeah
absolutely in agreement with you on this
and uh yeah i think it's a good move
that night needed to be challenged
and it was kept it was traded it was
traded off um
a bit better for white because d6 is a
bit vulnerable the big question i think
is once again uh how are we making
progress are we in time to push e3 4 in
the next couple of months like i'm
assuming bishop d7 rook e1 happens
he's done it yeah i think e4 is a bit of
a threat already
bishop d7 rook a e1 yeah we can play
not only that by the way and it's
yeah that i i'm going for the pawn but
no this is a genuine
genuine threat i think we have to play
b6 actually i i
think b6 and c5 is the way we improve
this position for black b6 is an ugly
move to make
but i think we have to queen before is
also a major major threat which needs to
be
e4 yeah i mean i take only four i trade
one pair of rogues i say that i
understand i'm worse but maybe it's
tolerable long term fair
yeah
oh yeah i think that's
yeah but then again if i'm white i don't
only have another move besides
against b6 i mean we are very happy with
e4 with white we're very happy here for
sure
oh pair of bishops are the potential to
open up the initiative as well a little
bit of a space advantage and uh a
weakness that we can
gnawn
right yeah and he's gone he's gone
he felt the necessity of the position
good fabi yep
so e4 uh takes like assuming i'm playing
rook f8
yeah i like rook fade better
uh or we don't want to be taking on the
fun with the king it doesn't seem it
doesn't seem very great yeah wouldn't
suit purpose yeah he's gone queen of two
first uh which is mean f to first okay
he wants to put his queen on g6
on g3 yeah
but i don't know i don't know why we're
provoking c5 i think c5 was going to be
the plan anyway i'm a bit confused by
this because with the pawn on c5 the
queen on g3 isn't really doing all that
much
we have successfully blocked any
pressure against the d6 pawn and the
kingdom g3 doesn't really support the e3
e4 plans
better than it did on g2 i think
this bishop is going down yeah the
bishop will will get dropped back on b2
for sure yeah
rook f7 by rook f7 yeah i think i think
doubling on their file is is sensible
here very much so
i would imagine
i don't know
rook f2 rook f1 i mean we can still go
e4 even here i think there is nothing
particularly wrong with it i mean
although it now it kind of invites a
four right yes your problem you might
get hit by five or four now and of
course you know you're very happy yeah
exactly we're not very happy
um should be two yeah hinting at bishop
h5 or bishop f3 d5 both of those ideas
are
uh very much on the table here is a 504
playable
there are some tactical considerations
too to be
but i don't think you could do a change
of uh
i don't think we won that yeah i like
bishop c6 i very much like what uh what
5b is doing here
he wants that bishop on e4 and he also
would very much enjoy the idea of
provoking g5 and having the e5 square
available and guess what he got yeah his
bishop on eve it might cost you the pawn
on g6 but uh i still feel like this is
an improvement because i think e3 4 was
a much larger threat than not even sure
it really does you take twice on g6 i go
f4 f4 f3 you might get mated actually
yeah the white king becomes very
precarious
i absolutely agree with that
um
because of this little sequence feel
like white is letting yeah whatever
advantage he had i was just going to say
that it feels that black is doing really
well compared to a couple of moves ago
yes i think i'm gonna have to play d5
yeah at some point yeah yeah maybe even
e5 and it's not so easy for you to get
he's gone
c5 which is a similar idea but
keeping the g file open potentially for
some play later in the game what do we
recapture with i assume the d-pawn i
don't like
leaving leaving us also weakness on d6
doesn't look very attractive right yeah
yeah on the other hand he did say he
didn't think five as a square
b takes yeah what
rook d1
that's a surprising recapture
for me i don't i'm not a fan of b6 take
c5 but let's see how it runs rook d18
and now we could perhaps
reconsider taking on g6 because there is
going to be fewer
f5 threats or
threats on the king side
or we could continue kind of banking
that and i mean something like h3 or
rook f2 or some kind of a you know ruby
g i like too it's very simple chess
covers g2 makes bishop g6 stronger down
the line probably yeah
and he has that and black is black is
kind of tied up and yeah i'm surprised
he actually cashed it in as early as
this i i mean i like it i think f4 queen
g4 doesn't work at all now because fxe
rook takes f7 black has no comfortable
way of recapturing
so yeah i understand why it's a it's a
healthy pawn but i thought black was
so tied up that we didn't really need to
cash it in just yet but maybe queen e6
was a good reply maybe wait what does it
work f4 queen g4 f e3 brook of ah queen
of sonia queen queen f7 queen e4 queen
f2 king h1 yeah this one i mean white is
better but how's white better e2 rook g1
rook f8
uh yeah how is white better yeah we have
a perpetual but maybe not nothing more
than the perpetual yeah it's a very long
line that needs to be calculated i think
fabi is actually calculating it because
a lot hinges on whether he can play a
four now rg1 rook of fate and yeah it
feels like i might actually have to take
the perpetual with queen e6 queen h3
here queen e6
is the idea
what
five wins the pawn on e3
okay you're right but um
hasn't why didn't white king just
suddenly immeasurably yeah just go to
ng3
i'm not a huge fan of this to be honest
yeah the bishop on b2 is quite strong
and the king on h1 is quite safe that's
why the white is better the question is
how much
well g7 is a prime target as is d6 yeah
a minute 16 for duda and the
fabulous hairdo is in the way there but
i think it's like 55 seconds
and yeah
was he on against core buff
that was an important victory for wesley
whose fortunes
that got off to a very shaky start yeah
yes
um can i play rook do i think you can i
think you can but i'm guessing we just
go wrong with gg7 and then we hope that
we can take on f3 next move well the
whole idea of bishop d3 is to play
bishop e2 right yeah i think
bishop b2 right away is an issue bishop
meanwhile did draw his game maybe queen
gabriel
queen of two peter yes just to invite a
queen trade
queen after rook f3 though oh yeah
that's clever yeah rg1 played and yeah
now the big question if you can play
bishop 2 or not i think you can right
yeah i think you can see this may have
been missed honestly because uh i i
don't see why you allow it if you see it
but maybe there was nothing better
um yeah and uh things are getting a
little bit scary for duda as he's given
the exchange he's just played rook f1
well if you take on a phone i think on
g7 queen takes g1 queen takes g1 yeah
that works out that works out we can
take on f3 twice but white collects the
entire seventh the king on h1 will be
very weak
yeah i haven't heard that before the
entire seventh
yeah
bobby goes rogue gg seven and now f4 and
queen e4
yeah we're kind of winning there right i
think winnie four check is winning yeah
we're very close to winning queens
you've done it you just take on f1 right
yeah he's done it well if
four doesn't fall yet but you are still
yeah it falls soon
i don't like d5 though why did we give
the e5 square for the bishop i would i
would have played rook g7 there i think
d7 was cleaner abby's in the driver's
seat here huge huge result for fabi if
you can
you know bring bring in the whole point
yeah i still i still don't like giving
up that square uh i also don't i don't
like from white allowing the tre okay
very yeah that explains a lot of things
because yeah trading rooks is very much
in favor of fabi here white very much
wants
uh rooks on the board
rook a5 rugby five yeah i mean black
obviously is like you win this position
uh in in classical chess of course in a
vast majority of both cases but in rapid
with the [ __ ] 25 as strong as it is and
no immediate passer is available this is
kind of tricky
you you are not at all guaranteed to
connect
no yeah in our case seven important to
player k7
bishop b8 maybe behind past bishop ba
trying to i don't know bishop bishop
takes b this reminds me i had this
sequence against hikaru once where i he
put something on prison i didn't take it
and yes he kind of looked at me like why
am i even playing against you
you don't know the rules of chess dude
like what the hell uh okay some tricks
there should be six workers yeah kind of
not not
he notices the last moment bishop
d6 was a bit of a threat there okay
h6 now rook d5 is clever
uh
yeah now rook
that's the finisher yeah this is good
yeah this is good this is huge huge
checks just take a just take yeah and uh
and
whatever and uh yeah it's not now it's
difficult to imagine how you hold this
for
uh yeah they're not even getting
involved with any kind of
king g6 or or king gh just going after
right
after the centralization yeah you can go
like rooksy for check or whatever yeah
but it doesn't really like from from
here as long as you say though that dude
is moves bishop a1 and bishop h8
shows uh you know some experienced hand
let's put it like that and there we have
it
because that means that duda is caught
and by the way let's quickly skip to the
game of lavon aronian of course cause
that's a big one that's a lot of pawns
yeah sir i know you like them yeah and
those knights yeah that must be winning
yeah and very very cleverly he moves the
night away from f6 to avoid stalemate
ideas he instantly moves it away so that
black experience peter yeah so there's
going to be a pile up a pile up
first place levon beating chef chank who
doesn't find his form here and we still
have radik against richard in which
richard
wins yeah yeah it's just winning end
game for him and they're falling like
flies i mean bang bang bang bang bang
but what what a great round as you
highlighted we came on show with
fabi and lavonne streaking and aduda
and
vishy unfortunately for him is being uh
surpassed uh but not so surpassed yeah
vishy got an important half point
against gabrielesko which means that he
is also tied for first
so don't count vichy out just yet it
wasn't of course the victory that you
would like to have to have and then
regaining first place but we have this
pile up on first place am i
counting this right well we'll have to
look at our currency standings side for
first three
what did you say about the playoffs and
the games of three players four players
five players
uh no the games that we saw were the
most important ones uh we had also the
game between korabov and wesley i can
talk about this one very quickly uh
corvo was a little helpful to his
opponent here sometimes you get too
creative in chess and that uh doesn't
pay off here after the move c4 you could
sacrifice an exchange if you really felt
like it with rook takes e4 or you could
just move your rook back to b2 or to b7
you're fine in every way corbin found
like somewhere in between played the
move rook c4 and the rook kind of just
got stuck there
after queen e7 queen a5 bishop f8
especially after the move a4 which moves
yeah a4 was not a good move
uh the
rook started to get caught and you were
more or less forced to sacrifice it
would rick take c5 but it was nowhere
near enough and wesley won kind of
easily with this extra exchange not a
lot of adventures in that game meanwhile
in the game of erotic against richard i
think there was a blunder right around
here we got into this end game which i
think technically is a draw
but you have the three pawns against the
knight and the rook but it's hard
because you always get mated rook b1 is
coming knight g3 is coming and this
moves king f2
and especially rook a2 here in this
position uh allowed black basically
everything because of the move king f4
and you started running out of squares
here for the rook the king doesn't move
because knight g3 b1 comes
on top and rookie two was probably the
final mistake because after knight e3
you actually don't have a good way of
replying against rook b1 because rookie
2 rook c4 rook d2 allows the exchange of
the rook something else that you cannot
allow takes takes the king penetrates to
g3 and collects the entire king side
along with the knight
so let's take a look at where we stand
after three rounds of blitz this
beautiful monday three people
tied for first lavon aronian
shishtov duda and vichy anand are
currently tied for first with 19.5
points fabiano carona is outside looking
in
huge victory against duda half a point
relegated from the leaders and don't cut
them out just yet richard and wesley won
with two points behind but that might be
a little bit too much let's take a look
at the rest of the games with our
friends in warsaw see what happened here
in round 12 of the blitz
ah guys what a tournament we have on our
hands three players at the top of the
standings and fabiano caruana just half
a point behind him this is going to be a
very very intense finish to this event
but let's see what happened how did
aronian actually get to the top of the
standings he was playing chef chenko
kiril and he started off with this
sicilian that we've seen him employ
against korobov as well earlier
yesterday bishop to e2 you cannot take
on e4 because queen to a4 picks up the
knight g6 castle and now we got this
type of position in which we exchanged
the dark square bishops and now white is
going to be focusing on the queen side
while black potentially will try to
focus his attention on the king side and
get an attack going via f5 let's see if
that happens b4 b5 knight to e7 and now
we see black employee a different
strategy we've seen corrupt allow a5 and
the exchange of those two pawns now chef
chenkov decides to go with this move a5
himself allowing b takes a6 changing the
structure of the position and we got to
this point i really like by the way i
want to pinpoint this move by chef
chenko the move c4 practically is a very
good decision objectively maybe
questionable nevertheless practically i
really like because knight to d7 is
going to come on the board followed by
knight to c5 let's let's see what
happened rook to b4 knight to c5 knight
takes c4 check the times at this point
three minutes and 22 seconds for aronian
he was blitzing out his moves only one
minute and 20 seconds for shefchenko but
chefchenko with a brilliant move knight
to a6 which actually just picks up the
exchange you cannot move the rookie
you're going to drop the knight on c4 so
right now it is white who is losing
aronian was busted at this point but
let's see what happened unfortunately
for kiril he was unable to convert not
only that he was on oh my goodness i
jumped a bit too much there
it was at this point give me just one
second to get back we got all the way to
this one and rook to b6 was a huge
mistake what he was supposed to do was
actually take on d5
sacrifice
very difficult to find especially with
let's see how many seconds he had seven
seconds for kirilla at this point
impossible to find it rook to b6 was
played and after knight to c4 it was
those marvelous nights that you guys uh
caught up at the end of the game that
actually won the full point for uh
aronian and right now he's in the lead
shared lead anastasia what game were you
having your eyes on yeah but of course
we were taking also the the last game we
haven't covered today uh gabrielescu
played against tv shannon and um
once again he proved to be a really good
blitz player i mean making the draw with
wish it's not an easy task at all but
actually he had chances even to
play for more right after the opening he
got this um this chance coached scotch
was played and then okay some kind of
normal development and here at this
moment uh bishop let move knight d5
probably missing the idea of white
knight xd5 and now if you take with the
pawn you get bishop b5 bishop d7 and
then queen d5 follows
pawn up in great position
uh if you take with um if there was a
queen yes if you take with the queen
then there is a move queen of six now
because
the rook is hanging at this moment and
look at this position after that it's
something what you're dreaming about
and you have this dream position of
course and he missed this very important
moment probably didn't expect that
bishop can blunder something like that
and after 95 he played just normal move
bishop c4 but after bishop b6 black is
fine i mean and not in trouble anymore
and then the position just developed
normally and okay here he found the ways
yes the way to to transfer to the nz yes
so the position was more or less
balanced after until the end nothing
seemed to have happened actually we got
this rook to c3 which transposed into an
opposite color bishop end game easy draw
nevertheless gary lesko steals half a
point from the leader vishyanan and
right now we have three players at the
top of the stanzas it's going to be a
wild finale of this event but we're
right now going to go on a break we'll
be back shortly stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back and here
are our standings
uh after round 12 peter this is quite
amazing really considering how much
vicious was running away with it at some
point some stage maybe even yesterday
honestly when he was like two and a half
points ahead of the field we now have a
tie for first three people on 19 and a
half with six rounds to go and fabi who
continues to be red hot despite losing
in round two today 10 out of 12 in the
blitz so far for five years you can see
on your screen
uh half a point behind
the leading group of players and what a
thrill for the polish audience is their
hero duda tied with vishy and lavon
and as we get ready for our next round
first we've got a commercial sponsor yes
uh and here you see uh this is a
wooden board from the 2022 american cup
signed by the players very very nice
item right there but apart from that
kind of a everything must go but today
type of deal you get 20 percent off on
the entire uh
catalog on
cubic.stl.com
with the code pl20
including including all the autographed
merchandise
uh valid today only so
wonderful and our pairings for gold yeah
uh wesley is white against uh
gabrielesko in round in round 13 vishi
is white against kiroshvchenkos who's
been i mean by his standards not really
having a great event he's a very very
strong blitz player favi plays korobov
another one uh who isn't really
doing that hard
and what's our marquee game i think it
has to be the game between rehearsal and
uh young shirt of duda i think that's
the one you pick
that that that's very very suitable no
question about it as those players and
there you have them yeah they i think
it's the 4a4
four nights again which is yes just
brilliant yeah
pushing nursing theory
pushing theory forward in leaps and
bounds by playing
by playing a4
not by increments huh
my um
monitor is not bringing up the games how
about you alejandro
um yes i got the game oh good
i don't have my games
that's because it's round five you
should scroll up
details details uh yeah uh so uh 4a4 d5
bishop b5 played by by richie this is
once again something that exists with
colors reversed in the pawn on a2 and uh
in that position i think you're supposed
to play uh knight takes e5 or e4 in this
game but uh yeah declines all of those
types of invitations and we now have a
very close structure
uh which actually i think often gets
very very sharp because black in general
is doing quite well in the center some
some space has been gained but uh white
will try to uh perhaps maintain
drop the bishop on b5 to c4 maintain it
on that diagonal and launch launch some
kind of an attack against in particular
if black castles kingside which i think
probably has to be postponed for a bit
because you might really walk into an
uppercut
run into some very very severe uh
turbulence if you cast inside here so i
would suggest something like a6 bishop
c4 queen e7 might be
sensible
perhaps you know hinting that we might
even castle queenside if we wanted to or
at least keeping our options open i
really don't like castling queen side in
these kinds of yeah that's all c3 yeah
really he's going to rip me up but uh
any takers for knight e7 and g5 is
awkward i would be if if not for the
fact that the immediate g5 i think is
very very awkward i i i
rather overlooked that the bishop was
already protected i thought i thought it
was forcing a response on the on the
queen side i was thinking no a6 played
six seven 54 recommended pretty sure
we're not taking on c6 why not it's
possible but i'm pretty sure like
spiritually we want that i understand
spiritually right it's hard to make that
move yeah tactically you you get the
knife takes another five yeah they're
definitely playable but yeah i think
that's not why we play this line with
white that's not why we play chess h6
h6 consoles and now that we've played
castles yeah
i was going to say we definitely don't
castle king's side because 1984 he
immediately still castle king's side
yeah by the way i very much like bishop
jitsu you do yeah it stops like the
latin c6 is the issue and black also
needs some counterplay on the queen side
and it kind of puts pay to all the
knight a5 knight b4 type ideas rook e8
yes somewhere around here i really am
starting to look at knight h4
because knight takes e4 i think loses to
queen h5 so i think we could have done
it already here he starts with h3 which
p6 yeah uh yeah christoph also
understands the bishop c4 cannot really
be tolerated for very long so it gets
traded off
um yeah this is a strange structure um
drop back in case of knight f5 we
dropped that
with our bishop um i'm not all together
sure that this is a great deal for for
white if i play b5 and you go song
you're actually open numbering uh yeah
an attack against i don't disagree yeah
i i think it's it's a kind of a weird
semi-preventative move but i once again
i think it kind of speeds up black's
play on the queen side exactly i don't
know why we spent the tempo on a4 a5 i
agree
this i do understand f2 f4 and nicely in
particular after bishop of f8 knight g4
looks like a very logical move because
f4 is is something that we also have g6
the fight for the f5 square continues
by the way i think i think we should
have preserved the option of meeting
before with bishop d6
i i don't know if i like this
something to be said peter 97 for sure
yeah maybe just immediately knight e5 i
like 97 yeah although 94 is a bit
awkward right nine h6 checkers exactly
so that's why i started opting for
knight e5 yeah h5 we go knight of three
like johann just instantly makes the
move knight of three but i think black
can still play knight g7 because knight
g5 rookie seven still thing keeps things
under control to a degree yeah it's all
about
the control of the e5 we already start
looking at some knight h5 tactics but i
don't think they work just yet
like you mean after night after night
after knight g5 g5
maybe rook f6 question mark question
mark
just to keep
just to keep sort of a
better connection with the with the uh
with the king side but yeah richard
after some thought goes for a more
sedate because sedate move yeah keeping
an eye on the g4 pawn making knight c5
less easy to play and if you go knight
d5 we probably want something like
bishop h2 and then knight f495 becomes a
topic but
uh if black gets one pair of knights off
and then goes 95 let's say c7 c6 or c65
black is probably fine
so knight e2 on the board
and alejandro uh i mean it's such a
tight race at the top anything going on
in the other games that has caught your
eye no not much just we don't have to
switch from the games no no no we're not
gonna switch just uh how are the
contenders
levon is borderline losing against radic
but he has he has chances so i wouldn't
call that one out by any stretch of the
america imagination korobov is
down a pawn against fabi but he has some
kind of banker compensation actually
that one's going to be wild yeah well if
i just gave up on exchange there to get
some passers it's going to be a really
actually a very interesting round there
is a heavily theoretical ragosan i think
in the wesley against gary lesko game
but yeah we should be watching the one
that we're watching and uh
and we did see queenie one not the
bishop h2 that you'd recommend and i was
actually going to ask you what do we
take on f3 uh with if black takes on f3
and i thought gf makes a lot of sense
right yeah just with a four or five
ideas right
uh we're we're seeing uh i think richard
is actually a real king's indian player
i mean he's making these pretensions by
playing everything else but his play
with the kings indian has been spot on i
like this the only question is is c2
yeah i'm not sure why i'm not sure why
we allowed knight before so easily
because suddenly yeah the balancing two
is under severe pressure i think we
might have to switch to giving mate on
the king's side but with the knight
coming to e3 the problem is not even
specifically that we lose the opponency
too that we maybe could have which is
bad enough yeah we could have maybe
handled that but our attack on the king
side will be so so much harder to
organize if the black knight lands on e3
and it seems like it does land on e3
like for example
the desirable checkmate is getting uh
cut off at the knees
you don't you don't really continue any
kind of an attack when when the black
knight lands on e3 and i don't i don't
know what we can do about it he's moved
his rook he's moving yeah but afternoon
what is the what is the follow-up
we're about to ask richard
yeah
now this is this has gotten badly a bad
name is played by by richard there and
for duda
wow
uh what a victory this could be the
problem the desirable bishop e5 to get
rid of not only gives up the e3 square
but more importantly cause the h3 pawn
and that will be you know played h3h4
yeah
i'm not sure what that does yeah i think
a good sign at all and and even goes
knight before says 93 is nice but
winning the pawn on g3 is even better
and i'm currently not being attacked on
on the king side so why not spend the
tempo doing doing that and who can blame
him
played by rickard this is just bad for
white knight g3
but you can also go rook g8 but i don't
think we need to i think allowing bishop
seven and queen e5 check is unnecessary
i think i just go 93 94 and queen
somewhere
okay
it comes to f5 as a check right maybe
maybe we don't maybe
recapturing with the queen on c6 might
have been just
too flippant uh recapturing with the
pawn yeah
definitely definitely was very
very uh
okay we've got it when i take d3 on the
board and here we go i think we yeah we
go bishop g7 knight g7 sir king g7 uh
knight takes d4 and the queen needs to
find a good square it's found i guess f6
yeah f6 is a good is a good movie a
knight of five king h7 just completely
killing off all of the
potential attack yeah but the king is so
safe yeah king is very safe on h7 and
the knight is hanging and also the queen
of six also keeps a good eye on the h4
square meaning that queen takes c7 is
never really a threat whatsoever
on everything the f3 pawn the h4 pawn
the b2 pawn
man that's a
an
omnipotent
yeah
do we waste the tempo on c6 here just do
not allow 95. yes i i want to keep that
knight at bay
c6 i uh
does give white does give white a tempo
to play rook g1
but i guess we just go to g8 in response
and we win slow
slow
slow it's good
i like the part where you started with
we win
yeah well he goes he just goes queen
takes a bit too very very concrete
approach because quincy seven
some stuff with discoveries yeah can't
blame a guy for that that's a good uh
threat that's a very nice pawn grab
there by
uh
yeah this is very very very clever g4 is
double check three uh
you can take only three queen of seven
queen g7 though you are
correct but now queen b3 and the knight
has no squares rook ca no rocket is not
a queen d7 check
the knight steel doesn't really have a
comfortable way of escaping i guess c4
though now we go knight c4 and rook c8
or nigerian
got away with it
amazing amazing he was he he's the great
houdini
let's start stop the pretenses i mean
lavon has been nothing but honestly uh
young sister didn't like i think he
thought the sun game was just uh trivial
trivial but it's not a6 is getting
picked up and also 405 is a threat
you you can very easily not win this at
all
and he better starts thinking that he
should win it because victory
has won his game is about to win his
game against chevchenko he might be
claiming the number one spot for himself
again wow
that would be better but marcus is
winning against horrible officers
winning but still have a point behind
yeah
for me by the way i mean this is the
problem as you're you get older in chess
uh you you end up losing energy and if
vichy were to pull this out
that would be one of his really really
great
oh what a move nice 97.
oh stopping all the skewers nice very
nice what a finish very very
professional alejandro over to you what
do you got for us a big uh we have one
game remaining let's go to the wesley
show against galrielescu matchup let's
try to see what is going on wesley so's
got a lot of fun got a lot of puns it's
an extra pawn but it should be good
enough it's got about to be two extra
puns i think yep i don't see how you
defend v6
yep and they're connected passers i
think that's pretty easy for wesley true
and just in case we didn't mention it
fabi did we did win yes so we will have
uh anandan young system tied for first
on 20 and a half and fabian levon on 20
points by the way
this is going this is going all the way
this is the sprint that we hope for this
is part of the
broadcast peter clearly going all the
way this is fantastic to watch you know
okay king d4 and d4 kind of plays itself
the hand md4 and rook c7 and yeah it's
it's not very difficult and he has 20
seconds
um
as long as
f4 yeah i think it's okay yeah yeah it
doesn't really matter i think so it
doesn't really matter a great deal yeah
knight c5 yeah i don't know i don't know
why
we didn't just play five of six there
but right it doesn't like it shouldn't
matter this is this is the big the big
thing about this position is that as
long as you don't blunder something
really stupid uh which is not easy to do
with the amount of you know solidity or
setup offers yeah king d4 now i guess so
king of [ __ ] g5 and just go from
eight right
uh yeah eventually you just play f6 and
you give him eight
rook d7 looks like a good start king e5
king is king of five yeah also a very
good yeah and now and now you kind of
resign because roxy8 is bad news yeah
that is bad news indeed wow bad news
good for wesley uh bravo bravo
[Laughter]
help me out here alexandra what does
what have we witnessed
it's the sprint that we wanted it's the
end of the race that everybody wants to
see tons of people up there at the top
saying this is my tournament this is one
of them vishy anan against chevchenko
he's got this weird position you see the
black rooks
they seem like they're active on the a
file but actually they're far away from
the king side and they don't have a
penetration square you could go down to
a1 but so what you're not doing very
much in that position and vichy took
full advantage of that here after the
move g5 which was a big mistake taking
on g7 taking on g7 he could take on g5
but i think the more human approach is
this one e5 blasts open the position
because pawn takes f6 is a threat
followed by something like h6 also a
thread g5 is currently hanging you don't
have time to take on f3 because of the
affirmation
he takes f6 black's position simply
collapsing in this position and
throughout some more adventures we
eventually got to uh this position you
can see that
vigil hasn't completely broken through
but black was forced to bring back all
of his forces down to the king side here
with the knights on f8 and g8 the rooks
went from their beautiful positions on
the a file 2 e8 and e7 clearly hopeless
still hasn't broken through has vishy
but did so with the move bishop takes f5
right here gives up a piece yes but the
bishop wasn't doing very much and it's
the fact that it embarrasses all of
black's pieces takes on f5 of course the
knight comes into play queen g7 you
never know when it's actually just going
to win the game knight g6 was played but
thank you for the material thank you for
the eighth rank this is just completely
hopeless for chefchenko had no time no
activity wishing with the commanding two
minutes of time still left in this
position absolute annihilation of the
blitz specialist chefchanko let's take a
look at where that puts us at where that
puts vishy because he has been leading
the tournament from start to finish he's
still holding on for a tie for first
place there with yan shishtov duda who
won an incredibly important game against
richard report and fabi favi keeps
surging 11 out of 13 so far in the blitz
and yeah this is a fantastic fantastic
race wesley wesley with a with an
outside chat with the outside chance and
we heard sadly uh really having a
nightmare in the in the blitz and more
from warsaw
well guys what a tournament this is we
have so many players in contention to
win the whole thing but let's see what
aronian did in this round because he was
facing voitacek with the black pieces
and after escaping against chefchenko in
the previous round another houdini
miraculous escape for aronian in this
one let's see what happened d4 d5 c4 now
we have the q g a queens gambit accepted
knight to f3 c5 a6 knight to c3 b5 and
now we have this very aggressive
approach by white with an early d5
trying to break the center and create
havoc in black's position take on d5
knight takes d5 and e4 of course you
cannot take on e4 opening up the e file
would be uh clearly devastating for your
position as black so you have to take on
d5
perhaps better was to actually take with
the knight it's all about the d4 square
after you set up this blockade with the
bishop on d6 if on knight lands on f5
for white then you're in deep trouble so
for example after a4 i'm trying to
destabilize your structure on the queen
side i'm not going to defend with c4 but
i'm actually going to defend with b4 so
that i control the d4 square you cannot
go knight to d4 and knight to f5 because
you just simply lose the uh the knight
now what happened in the game a4c4 we
see the same structure knight to d4 and
right now it is white who is taking over
let's see if aronian managed to somehow
defend this one queen takes b5 queen to
d4 rook to c8 bishop to f4 another
critical moment at this point after
bishop to g3 knight to f6 king to g1 h5
and now white had a golden opportunity
to tie up black species with the move a
bishop to d3 establishing this
connection on the knight on e4 followed
by bishop the other bishop to e5 this is
just simply going to be devastating is
it possible
you can take but then i can just simply
take and they say like this that is a
very good point anastasia and after
knight takes d4 there is another rook on
c8 hanging yeah yeah you're a piece up
but you're for forgetting about this
this might have been the
the detail that he missed with this
variation bishop to d3 very good point
anastasia rook to e1
quinto g4 d7 it still looks devastating
by the way for white h4 queen to b6 take
on g3 at least right now black is
getting some counter chances on the
h-file which exactly is what happened in
the game
f3 queen to h5 and now taking on knee
for assuming that queen to h2 might be
the only way to go queen to h1 and queen
to g2 when the king just simply hides in
fact that was not the case
queen to c5 came on the board
king to f1 is not possible because queen
to f2 so you have to go king to h1 and
the perpetual is on the board queen to
h5 ironian another miraculous save
what a game actually i was keeping my
eyes on the game with wesley so played
against uh gabrielescu and uh i mean the
development was quite fine i mean it's a
famous land which also carson played
against nipomnishi and um that was
interesting moment i will just go
right there right there you can see it's
a little bit like mess of the board so
queen a4 take on c6 so far so good and
now bishop di f5 move and here wesley
saw this this opportunity just to simply
take this pawn on d5 using the fact
there is a pin i don't know maybe there
are some relations with b5 he was
considering um and hard to say uh but
perhaps
later so it looks like completely
winning for him i mean computer really
hates position of black uh after that so
but he didn't say that he played queen
before which is also good i mean
stopping this king i mean from doing the
castling also threatening b7 pawn so b6
was played and still white is better but
he had to start everything from the
beginning right and later on i mean um
they transferred this position and this
white king seems to be more safe than
the black skin right here so he cannot
really cut so long and wesley was trying
to combine different threads on
different sides of the board and simply
one and mapon grabbed the pond and
started to exchange the pieces you can
see that his pieces are more active than
his opponents uh piece of the king has
still some troubles on the king's side
and um
there was also an interesting moment
somewhere here he could have just maybe
just changed uh the queens and uh
let's say uh let me show you like take
here and like knight g5 rook with seven
like the only movement i thought about
d5 just simply pushing this pawn forward
very good position but nevertheless even
what happened in the game was still
great for white uh you can see still he
has a pawn up and simply uh they moved
to this ending which wesley um lately
simply won wesley a big victory for him
but it is all about a vision on
and fabiano caruana going into the final
five rounds of this event we're going to
have so much fun with this finale guys
back to you in the studio thank you
anastasia thank you christian and uh
peter though the standings we have yeah
there you see the standings on your
screen yeah and uh the the big stories
here are and i feel slightly you know
bad singing you out but
uh what a turnaround for for richard he
really it feels like he really yeah yeah
has the scars from that turtle blitz
tournament he played in war so early
because in rabbit he was
he was very very good yes uh and only
the fact that vishy was unbelievable yes
prevented him from winning the rapid
portion but in the blitz yeah this is
four and a half out of 30.
when you look at the standings and you
see fabi and lavonne with those blazing
scores you think that's a very slim half
point lead what would happen in case of
a playoff please remind us beerus yeah
let's so let's take a look at the
playoff rules uh as you can see i hang
on a second oh yeah that's uh
that's still the same thing that i
thought it was yeah if only two players
die for first they play kind of play a
match they play a match uh basically a
two game two game match of ten plus five
uh and then if that's tied uh you see
below if three or more players are tied
for first it does look like it's a
possibility very distinct yeah they play
they play a round-robin tournament of
five plus three and then if there is
still a tie at the top there is an
armageddon game five versus four uh you
do get an increment from move 61 to
avoid those really really messy endings
to those armageddon games you sometimes
see and black has drawns let's avoid the
playoffs and see what the pairings are
yeah the pairings for round five today
around 14 overall governor lesko
yes yes that's going to be the
but the all-polish derby that's
interesting yeah that is also very
interesting because uh radek has been
i think this this particular day of
blitz has yeah he's been he's been a
threat he's already beaten some people
he's been fabi yeah he bit fabi he's uh
yeah and he
he is much better than i think previous
days may have led some people to believe
by the way
on the live waiting list how is baby
doing now quite well quite well he is up
to 28 45 after this victory and uh
points away from yeah from carolina
and weirdly uh levon is on three out of
four today and losing rating today
because he played gabriel
okay he drew he drew against gabriele
and that cost him more than than a win
against you know a fellow fellow
one actually is now trailing a trailing
puppy by about ten points i think and
five is within very very much within one
game striking distance off overtaking uh
hikaru there at the top
we're going to take a short commercial
break and we'll see you on the other
side
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see this
that's our show now go start
yourself.com
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody i hope you like
these chess door events because peter we
got more of them yeah there's definitely
uh
more more of the excitement that we're
watching right now coming up the next
one on on the calendar is the one in
july in croatia in zagreb the super
united rapid and blitz in which magnus
will play with the wild card yeah uh
should be it should be a lot of fun too
to see him tackle these fields and then
as usual the the the season ends in
saint louis first the rapid rates at the
very very back end of
august uh immediately followed by then
all the tor participants come for the
classical sinkfill cup with a very
special file yeah
yeah wild card not bad for that one
either yeah i'm pretty pretty decent
magnus carl breaking news this morning
peter wow welcome magnus and our
pairings for round 14 peter yeah uh as
you see uh the the obvious pick for for
the game of the round is their live one
with the white pieces against vichy a
half a point separating them they want
it for third vishy and duda type for
first dude is white against his uh
friend and colleague team-mate
compatriot radek wojtashek uh
and it was uh yeah four nights sort of a
classical four nights now uh lev has
done something very very
soperific in this line in the uh rapid i
think or maybe it was
[Music]
there was this game where he that was i
think round nine of
bucharest right where he took on e5
after the xc6 and made a very very quiet
joy
but he's doing something that you're
supposed to be doing in this line which
is basically play a kind of a
anti-berlin slash uh exchange spanish
type position where
uh king h1 already i think should give
you all the indication as to what the
plans are whoa
why h1 i thought knight g1 and f4 was an
automatic i was wrong no no you go rook
g1 g4 93 knight of five of course you
did that type of plan yeah that was the
first thing that came to my mind right
alejandro
just has changed
yes it has yeah i mean the engines have
done
remarkable things to our guys they're
the engines are rewiring the players
what do you think about that
to a large degree even though this
particular plan is not uh you know i
don't know why you're so shocked it's so
it's been around for a while uh the idea
of creating this kind of a foothold and
uh and then using the f5 square to
uh to create something on the king's
side
you mean something of the like knight d
or g3 i think d1e3 is actually cleverer
than my suggestion because the g4 pawn
will not be hanging exactly i think
winafan is also a nod in that direction
because it probably goes to h3 kind of
supporting supporting the whole thing
well you can't see the pieces kind of
harmonizing and coming together in the
way that you've suggested there peter
black is now trying to create something
on uh on the queen side but obviously
white is not going to react to any of
this and the queen actually spends two
time beginning to h5 knight g5 is still
not a threat i don't know why this is
more urgent
than playing knight g1 e3 but uh yeah
lev has
definite ideas about this yeah i really
i really don't like putting the queen on
h5 without the knight on the 5 to
support it it gives black additional to
mp because you do have you do want to
have the queens on so why are we
inviting queen g6 why are we doing this
so early
the thing that flashed through my mind
is that he might have been prepping g5
queen g6 queen h4 and saying your queen
is g league g5 is just such a i mean i
just drop it back to e7 and and say you
well you'd have to go queen e6 go back
to e7 or you'd have to spend some i just
i just i just don't even play queen g6
there oh you just go immediately i think
g5 unless it wins ism of white pretty
much never makes in this structure
because it it softens your f5 square
which you will
ideally be using for the knight which is
currently on c3 so by the way bishop c5
bishop c5 another nod to you know
perhaps stopping some of the play i
wonder why vishy thinks the hp3 bishop
takes is such a great idea because it
seems like opening up the air file for
white is something that white would
quite like yeah quite like bishop c5
confuses me a little bit
no knight e6 and does hang in e5 yeah
queen takes e5 was playable right yeah i
was wondering but i think it's playable
yeah yeah he takes f takes c i like this
for white i think i mean vishy himself
won a very nice game against uh duda i
think in the first round yesterday he's
done it he's he has opened up the f-file
thank you very much i think uh
will say knight e2 yeah c5 b3 so the
queen side has been and and yeah
yeah immediate c5 c4 and now we want to
go for some kind of 96 knight c5 but we
can't do it yet because the pawn on five
is hanging so yeah and the one obviously
immediately addresses this by aiming the
e e to knight towards the b3 square to
solidify the the queen side so you think
something like the btx happened and then
we played something and yeah our board
is not updating but left has already
played knight c1 i don't know in
response to what
uh in response to kb8 yeah rook ab8 and
he immediately goes knight c1 there
which makes perfect sense the knight is
going to b3 and trying to take away that
anchor point
six played yeah i don't mind playing 92
we do have to spend now some time titing
i mean but hey it's an extra pawn
actually he's gone knight b3 he says
queen 395 i'm very happy about so yeah
please let's just go ahead take a take
on e3 give me the e5 by the way that
would also hang f7 knight takes e5 will
be eyeballing f7 yes
this has gone wonder i mean
lavonne has landed on his feet like a
cat he's looking really good here after
f7 f6 f6 is unplayable i think because
of g5
i'm guessing you play knight g6
sadly because it's a poor square but i
think you he's taken on e3 that's why
brave 95 queen of four i guess right
that has to be the idea well we're about
to find out i mean that's a remarkable
the [ __ ] the seedbeck is kind of uh
discouraging there yeah the queen f4 we
can even take on d7 and take on a5 i
think white is kind of winning wow the
greed is working
uh take on take on uh d7 you can also
play queen f5 and win slower yeah i
think yeah kind of
both choices there's a lot of central
pawns yeah and it sure goes with an a5
and the a5 is hanging at some point you
do take that guy right maybe with rook
no rook f1
i like that i have d4 well now we have
d3 yeah so you have to play something
like rookie seven and then eventually
yeah i think we take the pawn on a5 yeah
that was just crushing yeah this is
cruising this has this has not gone well
it all feels that
rookie seven now we can very safely it
feels that after bishop takes e3 white's
moves were very easy to find
yeah
queen g5 queen takes a5 c5 was actually
locking out that queen you can't really
capture it easily but it was out of play
which is why levon i think very
understandably says
yeah let's continue the shuffle yeah
find a good square for the queen please
not easy yeah not easy
it's a time
okay well we'll give up the point four
if you take on the six and take on a5 we
can take with the knight now i'm taking
on d6 that's for sure right wow oh she's
saying no c5 c5 is unplayable now yeah
levon is doing oh oh
that was indeed clever levon is doing
this very very cleverly queen g7 we can
go queen c5 and then a4 a5 and then we
cement the pawn on a5 that's a great
idea i love that queen c5 yeah crazy
fight played very nice yeah
yeah this is uh
really turned out to be a one-sided game
bearing accidents yes this is pretty
much over we've seen our fair share of
accidents
this is a blitz tournament you know
saying bearing accidents is not very
safe
but okay uh just be careful that we
don't play a move like rookie three and
get our queen shot but we can go quincy
five again i guess so luckily queen
eight maybe is a good reply we can i
mean but
most things which aren't a blunder here
quite exactly
uh something to be said once again for
g5 yes and
queen f5 would you like to trade queens
know says vishy clearly not here you go
queen e8 but uh yeah we're kind of going
through the motions here a little bit
because white white has everything rook
h3 yeah i like inviting g6 very much
yeah g5 is very sensible positionally
but rook h3 was a very very strong move
there i like it a lot yeah
yeah visha is not very interested in
this rook a8 and now you go rook h3 i
guess and you switch to giving mate
because you know spending too much
energy protecting the a4 pawn seems
incorrect rook h3 g6 queen of two or
somewhere that creates a threat of queen
h4 right whether it be queen g4 queen f2
yeah
yeah is he had queen f4 what i mean
somewhere queen
yeah
i like that queen somewhere
yeah queen of four seems logical yeah
good squad somewhere
and this is nasty even if a g7 still
kind of protects against them but then
rook f6 comes in and things start
falling apart yeah
it's just not a very good position we
haven't even taken on a four yet how
many extra points i have two yeah yeah
normally one is uh oh that's required
but two is a little bit overwhelming in
the meantime governor has a very very
solid position against fabi and uh
yeah not much going on in that yeah and
in the old polish duel there is a huge
huge mess on the board which i cannot
assess without looking at it properly so
i will not even try i think dude is
doing what you're doing fine though
let me just as in much better refresh my
board sorry this is the wesley that was
the wesley okay the night the night got
to e4 and that's about to get to
let's go to the duda game against tasha
because that's the most more exciting
one out of the two
all right yeah that's that's the one to
watch yeah he will just recapture on d6
now and be better in that end game not
much better but definitely better
uh because of the more active pieces
although
actually i think black can reasonably
safely take on b2 it's maybe not that
not that bad at all for running but what
there's a quick the xd6 you can play
with xd6 right now you can also keep
like you can play something like 94 and
claim that with the collection of pieces
black steel has yeah
yeah just go for mate like rooker fun
rook f1 play knight h6 next go for mate
i like this i like this a lot more than
taking on d6 me too yeah it's a it's a
blitz it's a very good blitz move right
right right
you you're probably not actually doing
all that hot because knight h6 is a
manageable threat but right
but yeah it's it's a it's a blitz movie
that you that you make and well let's
see how manageable it is because it's on
the board yeah i'm not really somewhere
[Music]
yeah but then but then it's definitely
justifiable what uh what do they do has
done yeah
could you say that three times faster
yeah i thought dude has done yeah i
thought 27 was decent between seven rook
f7 is very very annoying in either case
if you put your queen on e7 i've also
got forks yeah yeah you're going to be
galore yeah yeah i'm going to be uh
this is a very very nicely not nicely
judged uh idea by byron
but my shoe is i think winter xd6 is
very very painful
as well yeah this is just yeah i think i
think youngster stuff is now a whole
favorite to win this i don't see why
queen takes d6 wasn't winning by the way
that was uh
uh uh
it was it was
it was knight five nine five is also
compelling queen d6 is coming against
most things yeah
the rook on b8 being
hanging
but
yeah
and time what are the times it's only 15
seconds for erotic starting now
and
keeps him in the game he does it keeps
playing the game yeah yeah
queen g6 and i take on b7 and this rope
is seven and so yeah if there's a pin
there's a pin why is much much better
because the bishops are unbelievably
strong but it's not as good as queen d6
was winning for example
yeah
and king h once
threatens the rather obvious give me the
rook i think it's time to go queen d6
there it is yes
yeah
and now we have to go rook g8 and create
some counter threats yeah that's that's
how it works you kind of but it's
unclear how to reply to bishop d5
exactly
this is why he's pausing because it's
just it's so difficult to
do
yeah queen d3 is very strong there right
which is oh
what a move what a move queen d3 yeah
and now we yeah
this is quite clever yeah this is quite
clever
this continues being very very annoying
for black but the pawns are disappearing
and also five seconds against seven
three two rookie eight rookie eight
please yes thank you rook g4 uh
knight before 95 i think yeah we've kind
of checked d5 no oh i didn't like
that's a big one that is a huge one for
the standings
oh my goodness and favi is currently
losing losing to gabrielle he's losing
to gravity let's go we got to switch to
that one we got it
three
and a half
but that's uh less uh less relevant to
our situation
and wesley is potentially losing to
chevchenko so yeah the the youngsters
are
you know making making an impact here
36 rook d5 from g8 i guess bishop b7 is
also not bad i wouldn't have been
creating passers for
anton
e3
how are you
who's losing
what's going on
hello
uh this is not the time to stop and
think by the way yeah yeah
i really i really just like this entire
operation
david yeah creating passers for for fabi
he's still okay but
are you sure i think the pawns just
going to definitely
be six
king f6 i like oh why did you like king
f6 what has he done what what oh he's
faster he's faster screening yes
and he gets another tempo with rookie
eight if you felt like it yeah that's
too many tempi let's go right this is
also a check now oh
f1 equals queen check
oh
okay yeah
yeah wesley is showing his fortressing
skills yeah it might be it is
fortressing skills might be a draw but
it's uh not an easy draw in blitz in
particular
we will have a sole lead uh young
chisholm dude is on 21 and a half and
fabi and levon
are on 21 with vichy in 20 20 and a half
so there's been a shake up that's a huge
shake there's been a huge shake up with
this victory for uh live on over over
this ship she is having a bit of a
nightmare today
uh lost the first two then drew uh one
in the previous round to slightly
restabilize but
another loss for him they might just
lose the agent yes he did speaking of a
nightmare
it's not entirely out of the question
the question that white could lose no no
yeah i i think it is i i i no
first of all the clock is always a
factor right yes but not not not that
much of a problem but i'm thinking that
you know what i mean i know the king was
was stuck
on the other side of the board that is
to say you put the rook on e5 wesley
wesley knows enough never to push those
balls like you actually might lose this
with like if you start pushing them from
g7 and f6 and i think yeah i think
against somebody like kyrie who is fast
and good
you never run those risks you just keep
the rook on g5 right and dark green
there wow whoa
whoa not allowed so those are some big
results alejandro uh highlight
uh them but we
we do have a sole leader uh peter
yes young church of winning that very
sharp game against uh against radic
where he seemed like he was always kind
of in control even though radical i
think at one point came close to
equalizing and obviously a huge huge
victory for levon or onion with the
white pieces against vichy yes meaning
that our two people who are kind of
crushing the bleeds are tied for second
uh with young shishtev who is having a
solid bliss tournament but not as
stellar as levon and fabi
is
yeah and uh you want to play blitz huh
we'll take a look at this finish because
black's pawns are just
a little bit faster peter yeah no but
trading those bishops and giving like
the the 5v4 counter play was never going
to be a good idea that was just not not
good right
he could have just very very easily won
without ever allowing that type of gun
to play he true did not need to do that
and everybody's pushing their pawns but
black gets there first with check
yeah and david recognizing the
inevitable thank you very much
uh
that was a big turnaround
and this is peter said right trading
those bishops and giving black e5 e4
look at this bishop right
monster bishop preventing e4 controlling
the queening square i mean it's just a
great bishop right let's play b4 c4 b4
you give a check if you go to e7 i take
on e5 if you go here i take your bishop
it's trapped you don't have to exchange
the bishops it's a trapped bishop that
would have been it that would have
changed the standings completely on the
top right five would have gone
down instead of winning
this incredible game point turnaround
huge just absolutely huge here for the
standings that gavrielesco was unable to
convert this against fabiano caron a
little bit of luck here for favi but
levon taking advantage of his chances
due to taking advantage of his chances
that was a crazy game wow
almost had another round of five
decisive games but shevchenko wasn't
able to beat wesley what a crazy round
we guys we had guys and look at the
standings now the standings
of duda 21 and a half he didn't win the
rapid he's not leading the blitz but he
does have the highest score combined
and
fabi and levon they've been surging in
the blitz just absolutely surging in the
bliss favi hang on one second this is
this enough he was playing he was
playing against lupulesco so this may
not have been enough
gabriel sorry
he's not
he's got 102.
is two points away from being the number
one blitz player in the world
yeah very good in blitz no he's just two
but let's go let's go to warsaw with our
friends christian anastasias to see the
rest of the action that we had in this
round
what uh around that was and guess what's
coming next round it's gonna be duda
versus aronian for the top position
let's see how that will play out but
before that uh i just wanted to show you
the game between korobov and richie
rapport who is just simply struggling in
the blitz section of this event and
let's see what happened we started off
with a benoni we actually seen this
before you remember that was there was
korobo played against swifchenko i think
right precisely and i think with the
reverse scholars if i'm not missing no
no he played with white so
it seems like maybe uh richie prepared
based on that game of chefchenko very
very interesting rook 38 h3 and this g5
idea now if you give me enough time i
will go knight to f8 knight to g6 that's
the plan that's why white has to go
immediately knight to c4 attack both the
g5 and the d6 pawn and then oh my
goodness
actually i think richie is preparing a
little bit between the rounds talking on
phone you know so maybe somebody is
telling him what happened in the
previous game so that's my guess he must
be uh preparing with his second most
likely which is quite unusual for a
blitz event especially rook to d4 queen
to c2 knight to e5 knight to b6 was the
move that we've seen in the previous
game knight queen 65 b6 queen takes d4 a
queen sacrifice
nevertheless right now it does seem like
white has the edge because of the d-pawn
very very powerful weapon that d-pawn is
and that pawn is actually going to go
all the way to d6 very very soon so
let's see how it got there rook to e2
bishop to f4 knight to e4 queen to g6 a
mistake because at this point bishop to
h5 was a huge one
the only move is queen to f5 then i'm
going to follow you
then you're going to have to go back and
right now i just improved the position
of my pieces that would have given white
the advantage he did not find this idea
he played the move bishop to c3 and this
was the critical moment queen to f6 you
are not allowed to release the tension
like this what he was supposed to do was
queen to c2 to try to make another
square for the king to come to g6 and
potentially escape any sort of discovery
check queen to f6 was played that was a
big problem and this end game is just
simply lost and korobov went on to win a
very smooth end game after that what
game did you have your eyes on anastasia
i was checking the game between two
polish players um youngster duda won
that game you saw the ending i think and
at the beginning it was just a good old
close sicilian and um with plants
well very well known once like rook b8
intending to play b5 and of course white
is trying to play
on the king side and play the f4 it was
important that after a couple of moves
black
after g4 actually black had this option
to to meet all this play with f5 uh try
and you know still to keep this tension
in the center so uh young stuff wait a
little bit you know moving his pieces
towards the center and here already uh
radek decided to you know change couple
of pawns to have some space for his
pieces um i think it was just good idea
he actually played very well until
certain point i think somewhere here
after let's say this move like knight d4
when finally knight jumped to the center
maybe he could try to play with
something like bishop b7 exchanging
those this strong bishop uh finally
developing his bishop but still i think
white has such a good initiative and
it's more difficult to play this
position with black right you've denied
some options yes especially jump to f3
so let's say if bishop takes b7 rook b7
like white has to find it i mean move
like 94 probably and i mean it looks
interesting of course with the most
chances for both sides so um somewhere
here there was
a critical mistake i think for america
it's already good for white the position
but somewhere here black played queen h4
um i don't know what would be the better
option but it does seem like queen e8 it
was the move but it's such a difficult
move to find with like only a few
seconds on the clock and the idea being
that if you take on d6 then i can take
on g2 and then i have this queen coming
to g6
so yeah okay very very difficult
position yes difficult to find yes so um
later on i think uh the commentators
were following yes we're following that
game and
yes somewhere here of course i mean it
was like a crazy game because um
actually duda had good chances so all
the way and at the end he managed to win
this game second time
uh and so we're here you see finally um
found some balance but still i mean it
was really tense not so much time on the
clock and the last blunder let's say 95
and then after like rook h4 and i mean
all the pieces
came to the game like bishop d5 the king
gets in trouble and the bishop b6
threatening threatening let's say the
bishop c5 so yeah
finally duda won the game and he is in
the lead
he is in the lead another uh
change at the top of the standings we're
going to go to a commercial and we'll be
back shortly with the 25th round
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to a sprint to the
finish peter look at these standings
four more rounds to go four more rounds
to go in wow
young stuff dude is now in in pole
position having beaten uh radik
voidership in a very very sharp game
it's a frail half point as we look at
the pairings for round 15 peter yeah uh
these are these are pairings uh the the
game we are definitely watching is the
game there at the bottom with the
youngsters of leading the tournament and
playing somebody who has tied for second
yes
who just won a very very important heads
up uh against vishyana a convincing very
very nice game by uh by lev uh fabi who
is also tied for second is playing white
against shivchenko and for wesley so the
big game against
uh huge game for both players as they
jump for position potentially
yeah
make or break game for wesley uh yeah
this should definitely also would like
to start winning games because he no
longer really is in any position to
continue uh
treading water but wesley if he doesn't
win this one it feels like he's probably
not fighting for the pedestal finish he
will still finish well yes but this is
not winning marquee match-up and what do
you expect out of this game peter
they both are playing extremely well in
particular today i think youngster stuff
is finally coming into his own uh
yesterday had a bit of a quiet day i
think but today had a horrible start
yeah with uh with a very poor start but
uh yeah he's he's playing well he is
he's winning games calculating cleanly
uh not making mistakes in on seconds as
is left so yeah very very interesting to
see what transpires and yeah first move
being made by someone just off camera so
we don't know exactly who that is but
right
and we
we were talking about the houdini here
uh alejandro uh
lev
he's
at times he's won some very very good
games but other times he just seems to
get so lucky what
i mean it's part of his magic your
husband says he landed in europe right
his tournament in bucharest really
depended on luck but he i don't think
it's he's done as much here blitz by
definition requires luck yes i mean
there's so much that goes on in such a
fast time control if you don't if you
don't get lucky in this blitz
tournaments you're just not scoring
every point now knight c6 is played by
miss carlos in the world championship
yeah we we have this kind of a weird uh
ready ready-type position in which uh
white i think generally kind of regrets
having played b2b3 this early
but yeah
i at some point i tried figuring out all
of these move orders it's it's quite
it's quite difficult to uh
you know pin pin down exactly uh you
know who should be aiming for what e65
is obviously a plan and uh
from black's perspective uh the fact
that we've already spent the tempo on
e76 is not that great but we can play a5
bishop c5 for now uh which is what uh
lev is doing e3
can be reasonably comfortably made by
bishop c5 in many of these positions
uh then while black will castle short
and eventually 65 of course returns
uh as a major topic is is that easy for
you to accomplish so e3 bishop c5 let's
just put that on the board
and if i take
is it so easy for you to get in that
freeing brake e5 uh i mean the control
over the g4 square i think gives me and
gives me a reasonable position here yeah
okay so i'm just trying to stop it i
think it's i think it's actually
playable in all of this but even here i
think you succeeded you just go e5 i
think it's saying okay
because there will be a
the moment the bishop on c8 starts
threatening to jump to g4
yeah e3 yeah
e3 um e5 is also a very topical response
here because it takes d4 you at least
need to calculate e5 v4 it doesn't
always work but it definitely is
something that you you need to you need
to address yeah rookie one [ __ ] p7 and
we continue right right bishop g4 here
like
these are positions which if they
backfire for white they backfire
horribly they backfire horribly yeah
it's it's something
something you can't really do lightly
you you need to be very very sure of
your calculations if you go for this so
uh for those of you who want to take it
a little bit easy
d2d3 is a baby step that you might want
but if you if you spend a tempo on d3 i
think blick is instantly completely fine
you're just playing c5 castle short i
mean you you you start thinking maybe
i'm already fighting for an advantage
there right
so yeah interesting to see uh what uh
young sister will do here but he's also
burning down
he's down to 3 13 12 10. two minutes two
minutes gone on
frustration movement he said like why am
i not moving quickly right it's such a
crucial game to burn two minutes
he's down
more than a minute and a half by move
seven with white and he hasn't been easy
yeah i think he really just liked the g4
e4 he couldn't figure out figure out a
way to do it comfortably so yeah he
spends a tempo on this
and i agree with you wholeheartedly just
go with bishop c5 just play sorry i just
played bg5 here and uh you start saying
excuse me why am i not better with black
it just looks which looks fabulous for
black yeah castle we
he takes d4 we always meet with knight
takes d4 even though bishop to xd4 is
also playable but i would like this rook
yeah i i don't think we're good it's
just not very pleasant for white at all
no
no
levels so you know clearly
clearly come out of the opening yes more
comfortably yeah i think this is a good
bailout actually i agree i agree um
at least taking some material off the
board uh
black might
want to keep the bishops but
unfortunately keeping the bishops allows
it's not that easy yeah to do it
comfortably we can play queen e7 i quite
like it's a pawn sacrifice but i think i
i can justify its queen a7 bishop c5
queen c5 it takes d4 we take it with the
knight knight takes e5 is playable but
with castle and i think we get a lot of
play there with rookie 8 and bishop g4
coming up
i'm not going to dispute that i'm not
sure
but i do say
though yeah i kind of feel like like
the worst is behind me a little bit
queen d6 similar idea yeah so same basic
question basically the same move yeah
yeah
basically the same move i don't think
white can afford to play something like
in c1 here so we are taking on c5
exactly as a matter of fact this allows
white maybe an additional possibility of
going e takes d4 yeah vishy vishy drew
against wesley already or vichy that's
uh i think he was black uh yeah and i
want to say that that's a
kind of a relief
at this level i think he wanted to stop
the bleeding and just get get himself a
breather and also beating beating wesley
with black is so not something that
you're guaranteed to do anyway so
not an impossibility but no no no it's a
hard task
knight takes e5 you were about to say
there's another possibility for one that
was earlier that we've we've already
gone past what i wanted to point out i
thought you were going to go something
like knight takes d4 queen takes d4
knight a3
as a second option for white but
okay
um
yeah that that could be done and it
probably equalizes right black plays c7
c6 you play knight c2 you play and then
before and i quickly make a draw and i
apologize for my poor opening play as
well
and what do we have we do have it's a
conservative option but he yeah he does
take on he went like bg2 and then 24.
which is i think a version of the same
he will just do it from the f3 square
and not the c2 square right he'll just
go knight f3 here now explain to the
audience and he played queen takes d4
right away but why e5 takes d4 would
have been such an awkward move there
it's a playable move but if i i think it
depends on tempe i think the the point
that the bishop on g2 is quite strong
and you you will have to spend the tempo
playing c7 c6 in the meantime while
white will start fighting for the open e
file
uh so yeah this is what's happening uh
quidditch six rookie one or key one
hasn't been played yet rookie one bishop
g5 should be four exists yeah which is
probably why it hasn't been played yet i
wonder i wonder if the one is intending
to meet d4 with e4 which is the only way
to continue playing for a while he has
played d4 and the question has been put
to him what are you going to do
if you play e4 knight e5 and knight g5
both need to be calculated right
95 i'm assuming you're follow up with c5
i would like to yeah if uh if uh if it
works it does seem like it's working
right because the white doesn't really
why does knight on e5 doesn't really
have any kind of
sensible jumping squares right uh the
the
the one supporter is not uh is fragile
and he took left goes for a more
conservative option eg4 queen g4
yeah these types of end games are just
very very level you take you play c6
it's very important to limit the bishop
on g2 and also stopping knight b5 in
some positions is very relevant dual
purpose move but it's an extremely
strong one rook fv1 and now we go rook
g8 king of fade bishop d7 when we come
out of the corner and
uh
black is just not worse at all this is a
very very well known structure in which
as long as you don't blunt the
knight take c6 somewhere you're going to
be completely fine
and by the way the player is moving very
quickly and
in duda's case that's a necessity yeah
he left himself a minute but the
position simplified quite significantly
so it's less of a
crucial problem it may have been earlier
okay
white is also of course completely safe
um
but it's it's just very very difficult
to generate any kind of
pressure honestly for anybody
very very quickly the move bishop f1
uh with the pawn on f3 dude didn't want
to see his
pieces get
passively used are we playing 65 here as
black or no
i think not because knight v5 yeah he
has he has done it but after 9b5 i'm
probably not taking i think i'm playing
bishop c6 anyway because giving giving
the white bishop this wonderful square
on c4 oh
i haven't even played knight before i
decided none of this i understood what
you were saying let me play knight b5 go
ahead and take it and the bishop on f1
gets immediately a very very nice c4
square yeah a5 by
a4 knight c3 he will i guess snap on b3
and go bishop c6
and richard in the meantime has already
won his game but he has fallen a bit too
far behind i don't think this has
a particular bearing unfortunately for
for richard who's had a very very nice
rapid portion and then
uh really tailed off uh in the blitz
it's actually in the like way below 50
in the blitz portion
yeah this is comfortable for black but i
was like interesting c5 and a5 uh is an
indication to me that lavon
we thought okay i can push a little i
don't have to play rook one i don't know
where that is going why are we allowing
why are we allowed to check yeah i'm not
sure why we're allowing rook to be hello
rook a1
that's a bit of a shocker i would have
played i would have played rook d1 there
as a matter of course
as a principle i mean why yeah why is
this why is there a rule
now
an uninvited guest i guess rook situ is
even
he's wondering if he's doing it which
way right rugby two rook b one rooksy
two i think c2 first
this is still an open question but rook
c2 would i assume
you know why some knight you wanted one
93 isn't that great and i think it's
fine it finally goes rogue beat so yeah
inviting either rugby one or rook a3 i
don't know which one you like best but
we won roxy too now i my rook will
actually find
i want to say
safety if that's the right term uh if
need be yeah on a2 91 b2 might be an
idea as well for white white really i i
suspect white hasn't done nearly enough
to actually be seriously worse
uh given time given yeah but obviously
yeah
the light is young yeah i'll get you in
the 90s so the knight is going to go
maybe to f5 i would like maybe
purposefully to bring my king into the
center another check is kind of annoying
right you're absolutely right i might
start with a move like g6 here that's
that's what he did yeah rugby so another
question whether you wanted i never
trade rooks i never trade brooks the
rook on c1 is a bit too active too
yeah but not b3 before which okay which
i understand but it gives us a very nice
c5 square for the knight on f6 right
now i was about to say for the king
nice i i like what's happening for black
and i think
duda has been comprehensively outplayed
since the opening or maybe from the
opening
yeah the opening just didn't work
what's your
what's your expectation for the outcome
of this game aleandro i think it should
still be a draw but yeah
he's on 12 seconds though 12 seconds
might become it's just very difficult to
create threads but
uh black clearly is the more the more
active side here i'm going to go with
i don't know about clear first remember
that there's a certain fabiano caruana
who is much better against schiefchenko
but the question in that game is how do
you make progress i assume you do
eventually make progress though yeah the
knight gets to a5 and you
somehow yeah for those for those of our
viewers who are actually watching uh the
boards on the side
the ball on b7 eventually does fall yeah
i think i think fabi wins quite
comfortably there although he did allow
e65 which probably wasn't i'm thinking
that the knight on c5 as good looking as
it is
needs to get out of the way so that well
it got traded away with knight two just
now yeah this is wow oh okay now we're
in this bishop's ending where
king should come to c5
6 might be met by c5 check though and
both of them are on a very very low time
yeah youngster decides no
not interested in playing c5 check the
king c5 yeah we are passive g4 kind of
allows rook h1
in some positions but kg3 is a
reasonably comfortable response so yeah
that's a clever idea bye i think you'd
take an h5 first and then you go kg3
that is well yeah if you if you want not
to yeah i think yeah
this secures i think this is wise yeah i
think here's the advantage making sure
no the two against two you're not really
better i mean yeah let's stop pretending
yeah no i like the pretense yeah there's
a little pretense here right
the moment this room becomes somewhat
active you're i live for these people
no this is this is going to be their
entire life is about this exactly you
can even play rook g3 here and make a
draw but nobody does that because you
might have to defend some bishop ending
and 5 is now worse
whoa whoa there was a huge huge turn
around in fabi's game yeah here's he's
potentially now yeah he's maybe lost
yeah wow he was he was winning
comfortably just very very comfortable
this has been drawn you guys were right
and
you saw that shake off head he knows
he's totally let go of this game and
chefchenko bishop e1 even stronger than
promoting because knight takes e1 i'd
have three coming and that's going to
pick up
queen this is a full queen
queen yeah
he's wondering why not why not oh why
why though rookie ain't played
and fluffy resigns what a huge
turnaround for the standing shevchenko
wow takes down fabi from a totally lost
guys i mean fabi's had a run of his life
yeah that is that is
very very hiccup oh man he was he needed
to just convert this one to be the
number one blitz player in the world
and he was that close it was that close
you had to convert this position which
is completely winning queen f5 queen
takes pawn takes let's analyze what's
going on in here black no space and it
don't touch anything right huh just
don't touch it just don't touch anything
black has no threats you can go rook a7
pick up this pawn and then just promote
it stop oh dude
you could you could take this and take
but why
but this one you should not take this
way no because bishop takes c5
yeah the game is now double-edged
now a7 just wins it just won bishop f2 i
mean
come on peter g6 here at things turned
around really badly for favi gave up the
b6 spawn for no real reason and he
started just blundering after the knight
got to e6 this knight is now secure d4
is coming f4 is weak the bishop on f2 is
bad the position in the clock was 13
seconds against seven but it was just
easier to play for black and as the game
progressed chefchaenko came making
active moves
you can see a couple of ideas here for
five but d4 played now you have to worry
about e3 this was a good move but after
knight takes f4 things are happening and
they're not going well for white because
these two pawns no out of nowhere are
connected and passed and things just
started happening e3 e2 coming
panicked in this position but he's
already lost and loses a huge huge huge
result here against chefchenko let's see
how that puts us in the standings john
duda
still half point lead still nursing that
half point lead he could have gotten
caught
by fabi but did not happen levon aronian
half a point less fishy
well
tie for third now
for third time
so he's a point away still
and what about dudes raid road ahead
it's actually relatively not bad
roadhead
this is think about it this is quite
something yeah
this actually makes makes a huge
behavior
how did he do against these three
players yesterday he won three out of
three three out of three yeah
and he's got white in his last two games
dude as
wow he's looking like he's got this
but let's jump to warsaw and get their
views
christian and anastasia
well uh i do have to say duda is indeed
looking pretty good the player that has
not been looking very good today is
vichyanan but in this one he actually
played a very professional game against
wesley so and let's see exactly what
happened we saw a catalan early on from
wesley wesley is a big catalan expert
but so is anand as well so we got into
this very very well known end game and
at this point we saw this move a5 quite
a nice move by black a new move and this
basically just allowed um unknown to
equalize handily quite comfortably
because wesley did not try at all knight
d4 rook to c8 knight to b5 a4 i'm going
to try to go a3 and rook to a4 and
attack your pawn on c4 so you have to be
careful not to become worse in this
position look to d7 activate the rook b6
rook to b7 and now we're just going to
shuffle the rooks rook to b8 rook to a7
i'm attacking the a4 pawn i'm defending
the a4 pawn rook 288 rook to b7 that was
a very professional draw by vishyanan
one point behind the leader uh duda
right now but what game were you having
your eyes on anastasia check in the game
um coraba fantom played with black
pieces against
slovak it was such a crazy game i mean
that's unbelievable i want to show a few
key moments because it was really a long
one um
let's say somewhere here i like very
much the move of watashi king which one
you know moving his knight after before
to g1 and f3 trying to protect the pawn
but actually the whole idea was not
working at the end if korobo would find
this uh nice move instead of um g6
something like bishop b6 knight f3 if
knight f3 then f6 you know pushing this
knight back and if not if not g4 then
black has this nice knight d4 move and
rook on the one is hanging or you win
the pawn on d4 yes you cannot take
because okay take and then bishop d4 yes
winning the pawn for black so this
position would be really nice so
probably white should have played 92
instead of knight f3 and the whole and
it would be not so great for white so
what happened after was completely crazy
but this is why we love blitz gamer
rookie for you know giving up the
exchange
uh inviting this bishop to take it of
course uh watashi he took the challenge
he took the exchange and now i mean all
this mess started of course computer
says that black was losing all the time
but look what happened after after a few
exchanges black pieces actually
activated quite well i mean look knight
is coming and then
after uh knight penetrated here to d4 um
maybe rook f6 was not the best move but
again i mean i don't want to judge both
players who didn't have much time at
this moment um now it's already you know
not so clear you know who what's going
on with those two bishops yes and so i
just want to come to some other critical
point like okay 93 knight takes and now
this he scoribo spent like 15 seconds of
his 20. he didn't take on a5 he played
this great move like bishop b6 very you
know serious move and after so if you
really take on a5 what is the problem
actually it was also winning but bishop
b6 was actually even maybe stronger
because you just go with your rook on
the c file yes it was also good i mean
you then you can play something like
bishop between probably rook g2 but you
have to worry about some blocking yes
and you know knights against bishop
always tricky
and so he played this move bishop v6 and
after that actually it's like completely
winning even though dash was trying to
find maybe some kind of perpetual check
after rookie five king of seven he he
played like santa crooked shay trying to
find something here but it was not
possible so what a victory for tom
corbin i'm really happy to see him back
to the tournament he's playing really
interesting chess sometimes it works
sometimes not and he actually has a
critical game against duda in the next
round big victory for his confidence
levels it's going to be a huge matchup
in the next round guys back to you in
the studio anastasia and christian thank
you so much for your insights let's take
a look at the standings peter if you
will as we get ready for our round 16.
and this is the story uh youngest of
duda has has a half a point lead it's a
slender lead but he is playing uh people
who are in eighth ninth and tenth
position in
uh in the standings and
today
yeah anton is having a much much better
day today than uh he did uh basically on
any of the previous days in the
tournament he's winning games he's he's
playing with much more flow and
confidence but still basically it's all
in buddha's own hands if he if he does
well against people who really are
struggling in the tournament he probably
wins the event i'll try let's jump to
the pairings and uh there we have it uh
anton carver with the white pieces
against our leader
uh
lev is playing against wesley and vichy
is playing against fabies so
it's very difficult to choose
very difficult to choose uh
what are you what do you think do you
watch
and then we switch to a dooda's game in
case something uh i mean the the game
between 11 and wesley is also awesome
quite relevant
we have three games there which are very
very uh important so we haven't allowed
alejandro to uh give his vision vision
favi the issue let's start with vishnu
all right fair
we're gonna catch our breath we'll see
you on the other side of the spring stay
tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
welcome back to the last three rounds of
the blitz and the last three rounds and
uh all together of the warsaw super bet
rapid and blitz with youngsters of do
the leading
but what a sprint to the finish we're
gonna witness absolutely with with four
players still very much in the race you
get the feeling wesley with three rounds
to go is too far away from the leaders
right the challenge for for much but
yeah the three players up top there are
very much still in the running with the
youngest of dude importantly playing
numbers eight nine and ten in the last
three rounds including two games with
white in those eight nine and ten
they've they've been clipping some half
points and our pairings
but we have the road ahead first for
duda take a look at who he's facing he
does have a challenge ahead of him in
the next round as anthem korvo has had a
very good day all decisive games for the
ukrainian player but he's gone four
victories and two defeats he has the
white pieces against duda a big
challenge there but dude is going to be
finishing off the tournament with the
white pieces against the youngsters who
have not had a spectacular section of
blitz gaviles was done all right right
but it's not been spectacular and i
think he's going to see those two final
games as opportunities to clinch the
tournament
are we switching our marquee match up
from anand and fabi or okay yeah but for
for the game of the round yeah i think
this is the one you uh you would prefer
any and fabian now having lost that
completely winning position he has to
play the sicilian and michigan as a
champion
it's it's too bad he went bishop e5 i
was curious about this philly
yeah this is uh this might be a quiet
one even though uh
in the
what i would call the old main line yeah
this one the c3 let's say knight f6 uh
rookie one e6 d4 d5 those occasionally
get very sharp those
those are aren't always
uh on the quieter side but to me bishop
d7 on move three is one of those
mysteries of chess like why did people
decide one day knight d7 is the only
thing that's playable in this position
let's stop playing
entirely i i think it's not entirely
what happened there i think what
happened is actually people decided 97
is the only move that gives you
definitive winning chances because the
position stays more complicated yeah and
fabi goes for a different approach there
uh with uh e6 and d5 with a nice steel
back on g8 inviting e4 e5 and kind of a
french
where you don't spend the tempo
replying to e5 because united gets
attacked by it but yeah vishy vishy goes
for a very kind of a
safe but uh uninspiring end game where
white really shouldn't be any better at
all
i think this reason i think this is very
very comfortable for black knight d2 and
honestly honestly i think inviting
castle yeah spinning the knight on d2
yeah she really does look like somebody
who
wants to draw
saddened by how the day has gone and
right and that is sort of is definitely
going for
b4 shows low-ish energy
show some grit yeah but yeah we might
we'll we'll give it a moment but we
might be switching to something else
because karma duda let's go to core
above dudas since it does seem like the
most exciting round of what we have okay
left and that's
weird it's a weird english but korvap
going for the victory there knight b5
what's going on in this position it
feels that black is a couple of tempe
away from finishing his development but
does he have these tempe uh i remember
this this might still all be theory uh i
i think i've i've looked at this line
definitely i may have even looked at
this position uh it's a it's a it's an
interesting structure because often you
get to take on c5 but obviously white
will take on c7 and then recapture on c5
black gets a very nice center but white
has the two bishops the knight on c5
often gets supported by b2 b4
these are quite sharp positions yeah
well of course you can also go bishop e5
the important question here is do we
want to play bishop e5 i think this is
what he's done
uh trying to preserve the bishop for now
ask dwight the question uh i mean you
can play a four but it's such an ugly
move you don't really want to even
consider it
you well you've played your knight to v5
you've
invested some time to try to get the
bishop the bishop just uh elusively uh
he does play he does he doesn't play
by the way the bishop c6 just didn't
work and we just don't look at it twice
yeah i think you yeah it's it's too ugly
right even though that's so dumb right
how do you defend c6 at the end
exactly
seven i guess and and then the knight of
e7 is kind of stuck uh but for bishop c7
now i guess we we we can take take he
goes king h1
which is a very kind of a mysterious
looking move and this obviously improves
black situation immensely the fact that
there is a pawn on the f4 which was yeah
it it also what yasser is pointing out
yeah eventually maybe the bishop ends
and ends up on g1 and just sidestepping
the the now open a7 g1 diagonal is
useful but it's a very important tempo
i'm not quite sure i like this bishop a6
is okay but the xc5 is also completely
fine which is i think what he did he did
now the the sequence of knight c7 knight
c5 will finally show up on the board
and uh let's just uh pause for a moment
and go over to alejandro big development
an important game levona ronyan wesley
saw we had this position which was
uncomfortable for black already bishop
on a2 very powerful powerful pieces on
the file black not totally developed but
the move bishop f6 allows levon to
finish the game found the move bishop f4
the queen doesn't have good squares on
this diagonal has to surrender the d6
square to the bishop and when the bishop
lands there it hits the rook and it's
not a trivial
attack because rook d8 gets mated after
queenie a check not only are you taking
on f7 there's background problems so he
had to give up the exchange but this is
dead dead dead loss for for wesley look
also at the problems on the eighth rank
it's not just the fact that he's down
the exchange rookie seven i think just
forces resignation bishop eight is the
bishop e6 the only move queen a8 and
rookie eight will pick up this night at
the very least i'm sure there are other
wins as well levon winning a crucial
game quickly here against wesley so i
expect rookie 7 resigns maybe he'll play
around for a couple of moves but this is
all over wow what a victory that would
be for lavon if it came to pass and i
think rookie
they're playing quickly you're just
excited ricky and i got quincy
there's still quincy five but white is
completely winning it's sort of
irrelevant rookie seven wasn't the
cleanest i think if the rook from a1
went to any kind of a safe square like
rook 81 i think would perhaps
legitimately force a resignation out of
wesley but this is still of course
completely completely winning for
relive returning to our marquee game
anton versus duda um
i got a feeling that like this is it
just worked out really well for you the
ball on the 4 is just really really ugly
as it's often the case i would love to
play f2
f4 f2 or maybe even f4 f3 but i don't
like the pawn on f4
this pawn has become weak suddenly there
are two and the the end game we were
saying is completely boring in the aland
caruana game is
fishy is a healthy-ish pawn up there is
yeah things are happening in this round
we've not really
we're we're not getting it right no
we're not we're not really getting the
the punditry particularly particularly
right uh in this round but
okay i'm not sure i'm a big fan of the
last move of dude which was he
he really is forcing white to play blue
before which i think is a good move
right so that you can play rook a2 and
get your rook into the game we'll find
out right yeah i mean are you sure c4 c4
is a nice square but it does i think it
gives white uh some things to do rook a2
ae2 or k2c2 and then i like 4k2 a lot
and levon won his game as we expected
was in there was no way was going to
survive that position and that was over
before it began yeah yeah wesley falling
apart today oh my goodness
rook
one goes to 22 and a half
pounds currently leading the tournament
obviously obviously young stuff is
playing the game that we're watching on
our screens uh he's doing he's doing
fine yeah he's doing fine but uh
well it's not as clear and uh and
someone actually remarked on how how
slowly and like elegantly he makes his
moves but
no
it's fine we have to 20 on the clock if
he continues doing it on three seconds
he's gonna lose on time yeah he has lost
games on time in this tournament exactly
yeah uh just pointing out juan paul i
mean i i think
white is really in a kind of a defensive
posture at the moment
there is one potential for him to get
some play and it's involved g4 g5
this might be an invitation
uh yeah d594 we probably actually kind
of welcome with white because it closes
like it solves some of our issues for us
the biggest issue white has currently is
the the pawn e4 is weak here we go he
does go g4 yeah here we go i think in
replacing your chance in reply to g4 i
think we do go g5 e5 94 though i think
that kind of invites it there is one
tree
five here the five g5 might be clear the
knight on d3 unfortunately really
doesn't have a life but
knight c5 is a wonderful outpost yeah
and uh yeah we won g5 followed probably
by f5 knight f4 like that would be the
ideal setup that we are striving to
achieve here
knight goes back drops back to b6 we
still play g5 to begin with right
because we want to play the pressure we
want it away from the f6 square
that's a major major part of how our
position improves rook c2 yeah gf is not
a move so we go
takes rook c8 played
the queen probably goes to e2 i would
say makes sense
there's maybe some argument to be made
for
something like f2 but all all of these
squares are very similar and i want to
make sure that rook c3 comes without the
tempo yeah this is why i was leaning i
was leaning towards queen e2 just so
that we don't have to think about rook
c3 but yeah he goes he he solves this
issue differently he puts the bishop on
a long diagonal
um
we don't really like knights
yeah i think maybe knight c4 followed by
queen b6 is logical
because i think end games continue being
fine for black because of how weakened
our pawn structure is we're slightly
overextended everywhere with white
true that but i liked what you were
saying there a moment ago where we're
aspiring for the moves f5 and knight f45
is currently hanging it's difficult to
organize you still have to you still
have to organize queen d4 24 yeah 24
definitely is something that is very
much uh
it is looking considered yeah under
consideration you you in some cases you
will be able to spend a tempo in h4
a5 why not i mean why why not why are we
watching this
uh queen d4 yeah but now we go g4 and
then take on a5 after what i assume is
queen of fate like i think when g4 is
being met i think 24 e5 yeah you have to
play e5 fv5 that will not work no and
now we go b6 is hanging yeah now we go
ba knight c4 and maybe bishop c3
xa3 exists right but that's okay rook c1
maybe i've got it just a6 yeah we i've
got a pawn on a6 guys yeah that sounds a
good pun
it is a good one yeah that was a very
good response yeah the bishop on b2
needed to be killed off yeah for sure
uh well queen f2 is forced right or if
we get that i don't see i don't see why
fv5 was so horrible to be honest i was i
was leaning off e5 actually
really i like queen f2 yeah but queen of
two is also completely kind of
and yeah there's this passer on a6 which
you you can't entirely discount yeah
anyone queen d8 to deal with the passer
yeah i mean he recognized
everyone
intimating that the queen captures on e5
and the capture on f7 is on the knight
should probably go to before maybe even
kind of now
if you don't take this bishop on b2 i
might try to keep it bishop c1 actually
bishop c c1
c3 bishop b4 yeah well bishop c1 i'm i'm
trying to learn tonight connects
everything yeah yeah a1 yeah that's what
i'm saying i'm trying to lure you to
play knight takes a3 so i take like
three times on e5 that's fair
rook f8
this is going very very well for uh for
for anton yeah he's preparing to play a
five now he wants actually h4 supports
the idea of f4 five and the pawn on a6
is still alive somehow i don't i don't
like him he really wanted that pawn
didn't do that but he's allowing his
massive attack i mean all these pawns
are rolling forward and he's running out
of space he's not even up a pawn
aloo contraire my sweet set pawn is a
white pawn on asics
it's not the is not the color of black
no
hgfg yeah that was a sad necessity yeah
yes but uh how are we
doing are we doing poorly at all with
black i mean grenade two bishop h3 queen
a2 is grenade 2 is very very annoying
yeah quinn 82 is a good move i love that
move yeah
i think white is
can we take the pawn on e5 yeah yeah i
don't see it i don't see why no but not
before before it's pretty good right
before c6 and yeah we were coming in
yeah coming in hot very hot coming in
very very hot oh what was this queen it
was just it's just it's just one there's
just one it's just one check i don't
think it's a problem knight c4 is a
small i think that's f7 at some point oh
queen is seven really queen g4 there's
checks now
there's chad
no what what check what there's there's
nothing i don't see four the knight is
on c4 yeah
why haven't we provoked all of this i
don't quite know but we're probably
still under the kitchen
clock what's the clock queen takes due
to we got one to one second he lost the
night
he lost the night and this is over yeah
this this has to be yeah this is
re-science except the the clock the
clock and that thing is
okay
there is not a check on eight to a one
actually you can take on you can take on
b7
yeah you can take on b7 it's fine
bishop like say one is kind of strong
and stronger than this right quickly
quickly anton quickly bishop e4 whoa
f7 f7 f7 f8 he whoa
is still playing against five we can
jump to that as the knight is making its
defense this is a draw right this has to
be a draw but it's uh you know these you
sometimes lose but i think this is this
is close to the king this is the king
it's a draw
but wow uh by the way anton beat vichy
and then he beats dude
i mean
talia he's five out of eight today
that cannot be drawn agreed a draw
agreed oh wow wow okay we've got one
game remaining yes gabriel esque gets
vitashek yeah rudolph is
trying to win but the pollen six
probably is too strong for uh for you to
convert properly in fact in a blizzard
yeah exactly in a blitz game i'm not
sure who is trying to win this uh i i
can answer that
excuse me i got i got a good idea what's
going on here i like to play white yeah
i don't know why we've not taken on a5
on the previous move but we can still do
it now yeah just it's it's a healthy
pawn just take it here exactly ruby one
c7 or yeah i don't know it's bad
it's bad for uh you know veronica yeah
don't fall even five rugby five is
interesting to me but yeah i don't know
you don't probably you probably like p5
yeah this is also winning now yeah just
king c8 king b7
b8 now or i like rock c5 a lot just
control those squares
nice nice nice technique there nice
place
yeah we can also do this yeah it's it's
a matter of days by this point yeah
before you can continue like pushing
everything forward
he finally spotted finally yeah
[Laughter]
another in every round is so eventful
peter i mean and the and the tournament
lead seems to be kind of a hot potato
uh let's take a look at the standings
though wow
this must have changed up i think the
situation right the lavon's leapfrog do
that things to do this one leapfrog must
happen lavon must be first tied with
duda vicion favi no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no sorry leon is in first and
second is a tie
no no no no no live one is in first
despite losing is unclear second and
then there's a tie between vicious and
fabi who drew oh oh okay okay okay
wow let's take a look at the end of the
korobov game which was crazy by the way
this rook on a1 yeah
61 would have been would have been
stronger than what i mean but
but we have seen queen f4
you know in a way i i prefer it this way
yes the man has ten seconds and he goes
queen of four in this position i mean
what a
this is just a smooth queen this is just
heroic stuff absolutely heroic stuff but
and there's no time actually
to check he would have been
you know if dude
if little sports quincy to check out the
queen of four he would have been
challenged yeah that would be because
like try finding a square for the king
there it's only f3 right and then like
windy one check or rook a3 check
okay
as well
if this if this game turned on on core
above not finding bishop takes a one
that would have been quite something but
in the end two pieces in the past in the
end it's enough yeah
wow finally standing standing and there
we go yeah the the
the two people winning the blitz are in
first and tied for third uh levon has
now overtaken a young chest of duda uh
22 and a half for levon 22 for duda and
uh fabian rishi tied
four third on twenty one and a half
wesley padding yeah and uh
anton corbett providing providing us
with intrigue
right and he's saying anton is sitting
there in ninth position
and two of those points that he's
garnered today or against some serious
scalps
but let's jump to warsaw for more info
from christian and anastasia
you guys are having a difficult time
understanding who's in the leading
position we are having a very difficult
time following that as well but one game
that was quite interesting is the one
between chefchenko and richie rapport
richie has been struggling today and
yesterday all throughout the blitz
section but in this one he actually
played quite a smooth game let's see
what happened e4 c5 c3
what is this what is this we've seen so
much nonsense in the opening phase from
richie report queen to a5 knight to f3
d6 knight to a3 knight to c4 coming to
attack the queen it makes a lot of sense
and now we have this position we entered
an iqp situation
isolated queen spawn rook to c1 queen
goes to e7 hiding away from the action
of the rook on c1 let's exchange some
pieces no no no rook to d1 makes a lot
of sense but the problem in this game
for white force jeff chenko was his time
management 1 minute and 30 second
against 3 minutes and 22 seconds you
simply cannot play this slow bishop to
b1 look to d8 queen to d3 try to hint
towards some sort of a mating attack on
the king side by the knight on f6 is
defending that side quite nicely and
actually it was richie that was building
up the initiative on the queen side and
this made all the difference in this
game because after that b3 came on the
board and finally my pieces are invading
and after queen to b5 we saw this
situation
rook to b2 queen to d1 bishop to b4
knight to c4 it looks like you're losing
a rook but in fact you're not because
once you take on b2 i take only one you
take back on e1 i take back on b2 and
we're back to even knight to d3 bishop
to b4 and after this it was just a
smooth conversion of an extra pawn for
recharge report queen to b1 picking up
the knight on d3 as well nice game by
richie report what game were you
watching anastasia actually after all
these games i almost forgot which one i
think you were looking at
another youngster yes against uh
radoslav watashi and they play these two
nights uh in in karakan um i mean i
think they both knew the theory quite
well of course until certain moment and
i actually it was a lot about positional
play and i like the way governors
quickly plays ending he pushed his pawn
to h5 at certain point i will just go
there i mean they change one pair of
bishops and now i mean it's all about
bishop and knight battle and okay if you
play like h5 and then actually he came
out with this nice idea he brought his
king to the center this is something
what we have to do of course in the
ending centralizing our king and then he
played like rook h1 and pushed his pawn
after move g5 he pushed his pawn to h6
yes you can say that maybe it's a
weakness now but h7 is also can be in
trouble so later on he proved with many
manoeuvres he kicked out the knight
first and then he played pushed his
bishop to e4 now asking questions what
about the pawn on each side
yes okay
and you know just play this position i
mean i really like the way he did it i
mean he found the way to and he won
finally uh he took the pawn on g5 which
is maybe even more important than this
pawn on d4 um of course knight came back
to the game but um
i mean pieces white pieces are quite uh
um strong here and actually okay he
played like 97 and here was an
interesting moment maybe he wanted to
play something like cook knight f6 but
then um e5 g4 i think yes came
maybe one move earlier i think there was
a moment when white could push g4 and
also asking this knight to go to go out
so anyway i mean the position was so
good for white that very difficult
position for black right yes so many
weaknesses exactly i have seven there's
a problem age seven two i mean those
rooks are really placed well of course
uh it was a lot of mess at one point and
that and there was there were some
moments when he blundered a couple of
things but uh overall um there was a
so this rookie six was like a mistake at
the end and um
um this was the big moment because right
now you can just take exchange one pair
of rooks take the pawn on h7
is just an extra pawn rook and bishop
versus rook and knight we we know it's a
better cooperation
this one just seems winning yes already
after that i don't know what else black
had to do at this at this moment maybe
just to move his
king somewhere
so anyway like after rookies or 9960s
936 was better yes at this moment
defending the pawn on h7 also now you
have two rooks instead of only one rook
so a lot of compensation because of that
yes so anyway after that um somehow
was much better and he managed to
convert this game and so what a victory
is for the young player absolutely yes
we are entering the championship rounds
and we actually have korobov who just
beat the leader duda will be facing
levon aronian in the 26th round with the
white pieces that one is going to come
shortly we're going to go into a break
and we'll be right back stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello here we are
uh
please shall we
live on
everyone's good at chess the one's got a
chess and this is our third leader of
the tournament overall i think only two
people led until now i think uh and
that's a youngster of luda and
vishyanan but now we have a
third leader a third leader and also
somebody who is now currently number one
on the live list 2854 i believe as
always always yeah blitzer in the world
peter not bad overtaking hikaru nakamura
for the time being there's still two
more rounds to go things would change
but yeah uh currently uh currently
number one in the world uh
and fabian slipped a bit
to 88 34. yeah he's not he's not winning
a hundred points anymore he's only
winning around 90. and that is
i know
such a full must retire
here's our pairings in the penultimate
round our championship round's coming up
peter yes uh jon snow is playing white
against gabrielle escobar
robert anand yeah richie unfortunately
no longer really in any kind of a
running for for anything uh fabies were
playing white against wesley and anton
korobov who has done great things so far
in terms of challenging uh the the top
players i'm going to make an executive
decision and i'm going to go with the
anton korabov versus lavonna
let's let's do that as our marquee match
up what a game we have in store and they
are underway just like that
yeah berlin defense on the board antonia
going with one e4 which i think is not
his normal fare and starting to think
after knight of six is
uh not not the great yeah and it's
interesting to see what he will do from
here because yeah it could become we
could switch very very early if this
becomes uh feel like
i believe come on
yeah this is not the most auspicious uh
yeah what
oh yeah yeah this is something e4 knight
takes b5
wait what this was a line right what
what excuse me what
wait what wait a second that's a whole
piece excuse me guys hello takes b5 oh
wait a second wait there's a lot of
lines the line is when the knight takes
on e5 first what's going on hello
well um
i mean uh uh lavon's looking at knight
f7 king of seven what is trying to
figure out if uh if this is a blunder or
or or a combo apparently this is
playable somehow knight b5 bishop g5
well let's see if anton plays it
instantly because what what
after knight takes v5 is not what we
expect and you guys wanted to switch out
of this game
uh
bishop g5 actually keeps the game afloat
and
i would like to see his face though
because uh yeah
if you play bishop g5 here uh somebody's
tricking somebody i think anton messed
up yeah this is not great yeah i think
he yeah something has gone has gone
wrong but yeah please don't resign
because yeah if you don't play bishop g5
you kind of resign here and he's making
hand movements which indicate a desire a
desire to resign
oh my god
yeah this is weird
set ourselves
up for a fantastic finish here oh what's
going on what happened people people get
tired people get people getting the 20
something round of the tournament please
he has to play bishop g5 you might not
know about this
no
i was thinking of the same knight
the king just goes to f8 of course it
does
and then
that's how you see it
[Laughter]
is a pretty good perspective king of f8
there you go king
there is negative there is negative
compensation here
yeah like this is just done
oh my gosh for lavon
not only is he escaping completely lost
positions
but he gets a gift like this yeah in the
in the penultimate round peter i mean
thank you anton for taking care of vichy
thank you
i can do that
and thank you for giving me the whole
point and then he does this yeah and
then he does this uh yeah this is this
is unfortunate and yes you know you got
a feel for the rest of the field right
right when they they don't know yet but
then when they when they get up from
their board they see what happened here
and and they see this yeah
it's not the the greatest feeling ever
no knight d6 yeah and i mean
people do have this kind of weird
blackouts and it's it's not fun and
we're not really you know
making fun of uh aren't unnecessary it's
one of the worst feelings in the world
but when you do it on a stage like this
terrible you just you just sit there
thinking like what what on earth
happened why did i wake up this morning
yeah like it's it's a really really
annoying feeling but yeah for for
somebody like dude who just lost to
a very very well played
played game by the same guy and a
fantastic finish too and the queen f4
and then you and then you look up here
it is i mean he just mixed up lines yeah
he was supposed to play bishop take c6
or bishop
bishop f1 is an automatic move
yeah
and he releases d4 i think by the time
he releases before he's like well
horrified i already touched my pawn what
can i do
right
yeah oh
man not great sorry guys i'm going to
recommend that we just uh leave this one
alone yeah because it's just it is
right yeah yeah and let's switch to
which game we can yeah what was some
consideration
yeah but the positions are very dry
everywhere like i've had a look at all
the positions the positions are quite
quite dry everywhere
i've tried let's go to favi's game let's
okay i mean they are such important it
looks like one of those results for the
standard queen's gambit accepted that
that wesley defends so very very well
yeah and in fact you could maybe already
start making an argument i like to make
players a little bit better but
it shouldn't really be argument
shouldn't really be out of control yet
uh bishop on a three you ui is
immediately drawn to the idea of taking
on g4 and putting the knight on on g5 as
early as possible but wesley starts with
rook c3 the idea being that you would
like to be able to
not get that rook completely cut off by
bishop c5 so he wants to get it sort of
out of the out of the fenced in area
right before he gets knight of 695 in
if all of that happens black is
significantly significant this is what
you're talking about yeah now 95 rugby
one and we we kind of controlled
controlled things too the nice thing
about rook c3 in my view is it does prep
the queen d also currently we we are
attacking the bishop right
yes yes receiver okay three is a threat
you should be six played and mean c4 and
quincy f4 i think takes takes rook b1
although rook takes d4 is still fine
right we control everything so ah he
actually wants the rooks of queen and
nine verses and then we go back to c6 we
play knight f6 95 we play f6 king of
seven and it's definitely black yeah for
choice but again a rather technical game
going on here it's okay i mean we can is
there something more exciting alejandro
uh that you've got your eye on oh
definitely we have the important game of
duda and gabrielesku because duda
remember needs to keep pace with levona
ronyan we can take a look at the
position on the board black is in huge
trouble he has two main problems one of
them is this queen on b4 a little bit of
a tactical problem for black as soon as
the rook on the on d4 moves where
somewhere it's defended moves like
bishop e6 will be possible and speaking
of the king side
then we have the knight on h5 that is
currently offside so the winning move
among others there's bishop d5 which
hits the queen and the idea is that if
you move the queen like let's say to b6
this cagey little move
makes oh
it's trapped it's it's trapped it's just
trapped on b6
so that's one way of winning a3 and then
just kicking out the knight it's a
similar idea multiple roxy4 continues
capturing them because the queen gets
trapped exactly the same way cruel so he
just needs to know that this idea exists
and if you go knight c6 then rook d7 and
now this bishop is attacking this queen
and if and again the queen is trapped in
the race and also the knight on h5 will
get knight on
h5 like rook h4 he's played a similar
idea with the move rook e4 and the issue
here is that after takes takes you do
have the move queen a5 so it's a little
different but a3 b4 is still such a
humongous threat because geforce also
threatened many positions capturing this
knight remember it's offside so rookie
four it's a winning position for duda
let's go back to the camera shot as we
have we followed this important game
dude needs to win to keep pace with
levon aronian who has a currently
winning position against korobov and
what about vichy too vishy is still in
the mix is he not yeah vishi is
winning against richard rapport by the
way he's currently up upon but still
plenty of game in that one left okay
as we're keeping an eye oh bishop b5
yeah but the the the bigger issue
remains that the knight is chapter the
knight is strike one oh yeah you go
would be seven which by three rookie
seven and then seven and then you go g4
next move and then h5 again
yeah dude will win but i think they have
these large screens right above them
right so he has seen d4 knight takes b5
by this point by this point he knows
this is sort of futile
well not futile but
it's quite important yeah yeah yeah
but this is over over yeah
this is also completely complete g2 g4
is going to trap
the knight on h25 yeah
and you said that anon was completely
winning no no no he's winning but not
completely not not as winning as as
these games are yeah yeah this is a
different level this is just an end game
with an extra piece which is quite extra
pawn no no
not on h5 gets lost i mean no i'm
talking about the yeah
in the vicious game yeah yeah that is
this one this one is finished
anyways let's go then
let's actually jump back to the
quarterback game i want to see the end
of that one because it's getting you
know a bit dicey
i'm not going to say that black has
completely destroyed his advantage but
you know there's a king on g8 you should
do it
that is a big question yeah black is
basically one move away from completely
stabilizing but uh
it's not allowing that number basically
yeah uh uh queen f5 gonna fight for rook
f3 this will this is what he's been
doing c5 is hanging and then queen b3
check you might be it's just
it's just should play rook f3 here yeah
there is no other move and now there is
a question because where do you cut
where do you hide you put it on g6 it
gets attacked by rogue g3 and he played
queen h5
in order to meet queen b3 with king h7
and king g6 yeah
queen g6 yes yeah you can throw in rook
d7 here you can also play rook h3
question no this is a huge move
is a huge move because i love the actual
threats
yeah i like that move a lot actually i
thought were stronger than they were but
they're still pretty strong
well if you take on c5 with the pawn i
have at least a perpetual yes at the
very least exactly yeah
and there the point would be yeah there
you go
it is now a draw after after queen b3
and queen c2 black has nothing better
the point there is that he wants to play
queen g6 but that loses to rook g3
correct or maybe loses to rook g3 no
it's me no it's mate it's made on g7
well i mean you go beat the xc5 there
roger 1696 but you're not better anymore
be lost after h4h5 or something he saves
this
he saves this
no way
we wrote we wrote this completely off of
course we did well it was a piece
but is it levon not the escape is karma
getting to live on a little and it's
time to play king g8 actually because if
you play 96 you please please please
play king james
this is amazing
he saves this what the
wow
wow
and duda catches levon aronian with one
round to spare because levoir couldn't
win up a piece
oh piece for nothing yeah piss up by
move eight
for nothing four really not very much
yeah this is oh my goodness amazing
scenes yeah and five is playing three
against two against wesley generally
speaking should be a reasonably
comfortable draw
but yeah yeah who knows they will get
and wesley's has a minute 22 which is
kind of relevant why be probably only uh
only on the 16 seconds
yeah and here i think you're quite
reasonable just take one and take a look
you never really lose those positions
very often
the light kind of gets a bit controlled
actually like if you take take yeah i
like not taking hang on gh
h3 no quint couldn't take h3
yes of course of course
and it's
remember it's going to be levon fabi
in the last round live on with white
and i believe duda is playing chef
chenko
with the white pieces to finish
having a good tournament but he is a
very good blitz player oh yeah you never
know which uh kirill is going to show up
yeah yeah i mean he is very very capable
of an upset there his
queen d5 check uh about to be yeah
pretty much with every move right yeah
it's difficult to misplay this badly
apart i mean outside of blundering
pieces yeah let's give me a chance we're
trying we're trying
okay
yeah uh vicious is still playing but
richard is completely winning so is
winning well he just up a piece right
now bishop h5
yeah that could be three and just go
knight c495
already yeah she won
fishy
game is over yeah okay so he'll be half
a point behind the leaders
what what's going on here
he played g5 for some reason i don't
know queen h5 yeah you can't pick up the
pawn because queen c6 yeah that was a
but still what a weird move the g5 is a
very frequency blast he's got a he's got
no
he can take on f5 now maybe yes yeah he
hits time yeah it's time it's time to
just do that that's check he let him
know why would you let your opponent
know that it's a check and then you see
family like from rubbing his hand
through his ear like what i mean an
illegal move check but that was very
sport that was actually very sporting by
wesley because yeah you could you could
wait until the queen actually gets
touched and then you can claim
i don't think it's i don't think it's so
weird no it's not you cannot claim
anything if you touch the queen
nothing happens
well nothing happens nothing happens if
you touch the queen now okay well no if
he moves the queen and presses the clock
that's made an illegal move yeah and
then but you can't be forced to make an
elite yeah the game would have ended in
a draw because right remember that for
people that have not been updated with
the rules illegal move does not lose in
blitz anymore it used to it used to it
doesn't anymore
and now wesley is ready to
make all kinds of checks oops i got that
wrong sorry about that
i thought he was going to play another
sequence of checks yeah yeah but it
doesn't matter no
yeah
he's kind of like a [ __ ] oh no queen b4
check what a cheapo artist uh
fabby has become what well it's defended
crazy guy he's defending yeah he is
obscured he thought he lost his swing
nice gear yeah he's fine right you can
go king come on go king e4
26 mate hey
you wanted me i was worried about the
skewer not the mate you wanted that
didn't you no i did not hang on is this
mage it's me he got major he made it
what a result he got made
how did he get mated it was a queen and
a bishop against the queen what what
what
it's king went all the way back
guys guys i think everybody's gotten
tired i think we're all losing it i mean
you guys these guys come from three
tournaments i mean we do two american
cup
bucharest and warsaw and this is going
to be their break this is their last day
for a lot of these players before big
other tournaments coming up
and i think they're just losing it guys
wesley should never lose queen
his queen and bishop versus it's
unnecessary that is it's very very
unnecessary wow
truly levon didn't win up a piece
that was even more amazing than this
yeah i mean come on that's just crazy
really things are things are yeah
heating up you can stay
a bit yeah
a tiny bit
what
what what what are the standings uh
we're about to follow
yeah we have we have two people on 23
points and two people in 22 and a half
points and two of them are playing each
other each other
the script writer's dream it's often
very often yeah it happens
we do have the two top finishers playing
each other in the last round so
everything to play before
are leading on 23. they're not playing
each other then they want to play favi
right one's playing fabi yeah and uh
dude is playing uh
and what is she playing
uh
one sec vichy is playing
why is this so difficult
right
yeah yeah yeah here it is here are the
pairings anand with white against
voitashik
aronian against caruana
and shivchenko duda three games that we
cannot miss
that could determine the first place it
could determine the first place four
people could still be the winner of this
tournament
i don't want that
i don't want to hear playoffs with four
players playing for playoffs
i don't think we can get up no we can
get a three we can get a three right i
don't think we're gonna get a four yeah
four is impossible but three is max's
three thank goodness thank goodness
because the regulations break on
[Laughter]
a teary-eyed arbiter will come yeah that
way
the playoff scenario guys we can't
accommodate you so if if there's a
simple two-way type of first they play a
match of ten plus five and then
potentially in armageddon if it's one
one if it's three players they will play
a round robin of five plus three and
once again if there's a tie at the top
there will be an armageddon game and for
the armageddon game it's five versus
four with increments starting from of 61
to avoid clock banging and uh black has
draws yeah this is a bit striking i
haven't seen the one not win pizza
positions very often and let's see the
end of that game that keeps fabi's
chances alive
and yeah another fun night of fight and
look at how this would have changed the
fabio is on the line look at five he
reaches for the queen he wants to give a
check intermediate check with the queen
and then
wesley's like wait a second dude i don't
have five is attacking your king on e3
enough having
go goes with his and it threw his ear
and then he goes on fire goes on to beat
him from this position by the way yeah
why not why not
wow what a turnaround of things what a
turnaround of the tournament what a
tournament i don't think i've cast a
grand chest tour in which in the last
round four people could win i've cast
worth three i think could win two for
sure a lot of guys i've casted many
grand chess tours where this event was
over two rounds to go
yeah and here we have this wow just
crazy let's go to our friends in warsaw
and their opinions on what's going on
one more round of blitz before potential
playoffs or we crown a champion
so uh who hired steven spielberg to
write the script for uh this event
because this is just insane four players
still in contention to win this one this
is just incredible but let's see how
anand actually want to put himself in
contention with the black pieces against
the struggling ritchie report richie
with the white pcc started off with this
move d3 a lot of
we've seen a lot of this type of stuff
from richie in this event and he's
continuing to employ his usual strategy
to try to confuse his opponents out of
the opening g3 and we get this position
it's very difficult by the way to
confuse vichy or nun who has so much
experience with this type of openings
and this is exactly what happened it was
actually vishy who took uh
full control of this position out of the
opening i would say equalized at least
perhaps a better position with the black
pieces equalized at least i'm looking at
the bishops the bishop one d7 definitely
has a lot more potential potentially
going to c6 the bishop g2 just eyeing
his own pawn i don't like it so let's
see what happened rook to d1 queen to e7
bishop to c4 bishop to e6 queen to c6
and now we got into this end game
and after b4 unfortunately forgot that
there is a pawn on a4 that you will be
losing it and that's upon up four black
pawn to the good and it was actually a
very smooth sailing for vision on in the
end game after queen to d4 we exchanged
the queens two past pawns for black and
white with only 34 seconds richie report
34 seconds against one minute and 47
seconds for vishyanan he was unable to
hold control of this position and
vishyanan goes on to win this game and
gets half a point close to the leader of
this event anastasia what game were you
having your eyes on um the game which is
doesn't have such a crucial let's say
um meaning for the standings it was
between
um
against um
yes that one and okay i will just go
quickly here and d5 was the move which
managed um
which gave the quality for shivchenko i
guess after bishop defy i think he got
really comfortable for position
i will i will just scroll down to show
another uh important moment after queen
c4 he could have just changed the queens
and go for the ending quest extra pawn
of course with some problems because
white pieces are quite active as you can
see on the board so probably white is
not really worse
but he played move queen b1 here
allowing white to take on f7 yes knight
f7 water blow and after king of seven
rook g7 now i mean really black is in
danger so what happened in the end is
that they came to this position also
uh and here uh tasha gave uh a perpetual
check as we know at the end it was a
draw but actually he could try to play
still this position for them what are we
doing on time at this point
of course it was hard for both sides i
mean with seconds on the clock but you
had to find the the correct plan yes you
had to push your pawns g4 f5 and
actually understand that those pawns are
going quicker than your opponent's uh
bones i mean there was a nice variation
yes if black starts i mean if you start
maybe something like g4
exactly yes schedule so for example if
black plays like something like a4 there
is a nice three queen c8 and then queen
g7 winning this pawn on a4 so this one
cannot run so quickly and then white
just proceed with g4 f5 and but okay it
was really hard
to see it all in with seconds on the
clock very difficult to assess this one
white does seem to be a bit faster
pushing his pawns on the king's side
nevertheless a big game big result for
chef chenko and right now he will have
to defend with the white pieces against
duda who definitely wants to win that
one duda and levon aronian are they
going to win or
maybe caruana and vichyanan could have a
chance caruana actually is playing levon
aronian in the final game this one is
going to be wild guys back to you in the
studio thank you very much anastasia and
christian indeed this is it the
championship round everybody
as we have
a very exciting finish here peter very
much so
yeah the bearings for the last round are
the the most important ones are of
course the game between uh fabian lev
there at the bottom uh the game uh duda
is playing with the black pieces against
uh kiroshenko and uh vichy is playing
somebody who knows
very really well and vice versa of
course yeah radical
being his long long time second and
friend
uh wow
wow uh uh what a great finish and uh
yes in case there is a tie we do promise
you in case there is a tie there will be
there will play offs and uh
this is feels feels feels right if there
is uh yeah
that's how this has been this has been
going this entire day it also would feel
weird yeah we have tie for first four
players ties but this is the price money
what they're playing for over there in
warsaw forty thousand for first place
thirty thousand per second remember
those gct points are hugely important
for the players as they accumulate them
it's another hundred thousand dollars
for the first place of the gct tour at
the end of the sink field cup as well
know who accumulated the most amount of
points vishy taking a fair amount of
these wild cards points so let's do that
i was about to say munch munching away a
lot of these points yeah and as we
prepare for this our final broadcast of
the warsaw grand chess tour we'd just
like to express some thanks peter
absolutely there's some really really
marvelous people behind the scenes that
make it all happen from the people here
at the st louis chess club as well as
our production who are they all yeah
let's uh let's go through the list there
i will actually read this off the list
because i will otherwise make mistakes
and forget starting starting from the
top uh are you know
much many things to gary gary kasparov
and michael hilakowski the people who
were at the at the outset uh you know
the
store yeah the the people without home
detour would not have existed and uh
obviously a huge thanks to uh rex and
jeannie uh singhfield uh to to joy tony
ryan and rebecca who's been uh you know
instrumental in making it all run
smoothly and uh emily too and yeah thank
you where are you
coffee coffee emily
yeah uh the the spectrum team uh
randy and and dugan and and the rest of
that team uh
who are over in warsaw with brian and
marcus and and the team who is running
the production here the silverback team
with kevin and and tom and kitty and
tyler and the people who have been
keeping up with our tantrums and uh
you know and
providing a never-ending stream of
special thank you dad jokes in in our
ears yeah special thanks to tyler for
always making sure that we're on set
with two minutes to spare that is very
very important
and of course special thanks to the
super bet foundation for sponsoring the
entire thing and to to everyone in the
st louis chess club for
well being the saint louis chess club
which is uh you know without the saint
louis chess club the chess scene in the
world would have been much the poorer no
question about it and again uh big
thanks to the club as well as yourselves
i mean peter alejandro we're groggy or
dizzy with tiredness but it's been
really really marvelous and anas
anastasia and christian and warsaw as
well thank you all that was really
really cool as we come to our
championship round
predictions no predictions no no no no
no
not with the way the last couple of
rounds have been killed
the last couple of rounds have been such
a roller coaster of emotions right in
like every game core above aronian you
drop a piece of move seven yeah and then
aronian barely makes a draw
i mean it scrapes to a draw above duda
there's like
white can checkmate black in every way
finds the one losing he's actually
losing he was actually losing and in
time pressure doesn't find it right huge
swing right then you got favi
against wesley where wesley tells his
opponent
dude you're in check
stop reaching for your queen oh thanks
i'll beat you thank you
thank you i will beat you from a dead
drawn position
that's a
sign of my gratitude yeah yeah let's
continue playing from there and can you
please blundermate i gotta i gotta point
it out how about vishy okay i mean he's
disappointed but he is leading the
tournament he continues fighting he
continues fighting that's what i want to
say he fell off his perch
and if he had faded badly everybody
would have said hey dude you had great
for the first four days too bad about
the fifth but he's still in there he's
still in there yeah i mean he's he's
he's had a very poor day by his tennis
he's on minus one with that victory with
black against ritchie he's he's on minus
one today still not doing well at all
but he's still very much in with the
shout if he wins in the last round
there's a very real possibility he is in
the tie break for first player wow
and there it is as the players get ready
on the stage i can just imagine that in
warsaw the atmosphere
must be like come on
come on dude
and this is such a huge game for vichy
this is how he started the tournament
remember he started the tournament
beating voitacic with the white pieces
in the spanish right now he's going to
finish the event with the white pieces
again against radic i think if if you
have to take a favorite here it has to
be dude because he is playing the you
know nominally the softer the softer
opponent he's playing somebody who's not
been playing well in the tournament with
the white pieces and uh
levon is playing against fabian fabi has
had
i mean not as good a day as yesterday
but still a very very good day fabi is
on uh five and a half out of eight plus
three score today really a very fine
score exactly you realize he scored like
eight out of nine yesterday
and this will be our marquee matchup
right here lavon versus
and the crazy part is one two three in
the world live rating list are all
american all-american and we're going to
find out who is leading the world blitz
ranking after this game is it going to
be
or is it going to be fabiano caruana
yeah five years old or 28 46 cara
nakamura no there's no there's no way a
draw no
a draw leaves levanas number one
is that so okay i wouldn't have guessed
that okay
[Applause]
providing us with wonderful pictures
truly very very restrained hair color
yeah what is this we can't we i couldn't
recognize him
i was looking for the purple
where's leonard where's
where's the bright green yeah right
you're correct
oh by the way big shout out to the
players too there we go it's been
exhausting guys there we go guys
iii at some point before you started
this bishop c4 foolishness he was
actually very active in uh in playing
this with the white pieces he has
a lot of very very recent knowledge
these are very very sharp positions and
very interesting to play and by the way
i mean it we it's so rare that we're
seeing in just an open spanish
that sometimes you kind of forget what
you're doing and h7h5 came out instantly
yeah
we've watched a very very exciting game
in this line in bucharest there was this
game between linear dominguez and bogdan
dayak yes which went b595 from here but
the fabid deviates by playing queen c7
uh
also a very uh reasonable move of course
no that was rook c8 not not not b5 rook
c8 95 quincy seven is similar to roxy8
in some in some ways and uh
uh obviously different in others uh the
rook might not go to c8 at all the other
rook might go to c8 even though black
generally doesn't castle king side too
early because you are castling sort of
into it even though the palm h5 provides
very very significant cover against the
normal plans on the king's side
from white's point of view is he trying
to play knight d5 enforcement kind of
especially
yeah 95 is one way and the other one
would be to play something like you
could include h3h4 and i think often
they do include h3o but okay this is
irrelevant right and this is the
difference between rook c8 and queen c7
i'm guessing is that now we take not
with the bishop in knight b6 we take
instead
uh with the knight and we go bishop by
five
and bishop d3 right away take stakes we
play rook c8 here we play we play for
quincy four and ob5 with the not similar
ideas really with the ball mp5 you're
just trying to stop c4 yeah this is why
i also wanted to play rook c8 but b5
creates a very very obvious target for
white if you could somehow get the
knight to a5 and c6 you are very very
happy
which is why perhaps queen c4 is
borderline unplayable on the next move
because of knight a5 so um
queen c4 allowing knight a5 because it'd
be a huge strategy and the reason i keep
on mentioning quincy iv is that
sort of common wisdom says sicilian
endgames in most cases are good for
black right uh but not if not if the
white knight lands on c6 and bishop d2
instantly you know an indication that uh
le lev knows what you're supposed to be
aiming for in this type of position
should should black be aspiring for
knight c5 i think it's it's definitely a
playable move but white is not even
obliged to react i think it sounds like
we need to and yeah here we go
let's see if we can park the knight on
c6 let a5 maybe we go something like f5
knight c6 knight b8
f5
generally generally you do play five in
this in these structures you want to
rook aca i guess he is once again he's
inviting that into c6 to immediately uh
challenge the knight b8 yeah which is
why i think maybe rook c1 is more
precise
for g4 maybe maybe like f6 another six
with the idea of knight takes d5 as well
yeah
which is why we playing roxy one trying
to prepare c34 i like this for white i'm
not sure exactly why fabi uh played b5
so early i don't think it was required
he could have he could have been more
flexible there on the queen's side well
the nice part about c4 is that if i do
end up capturing
with the rook then the c6 square is well
and truly under my control yeah it's
it's a difficult uh difficult decision
already for black maybe bishop g5 you
know bishop if i'm wondering the g6 pawn
after bishop takes queen takes a5 bhp
seven
uh knight b6 played kinda stopping both
things b2 b3 looks ugly but might be
required
is there a way to be
very very like i want to play knight c4
here but i don't think it works
around yeah
getting inspired by anton's piece
sacrifices
i think it's it's it's it's not as
stupid as you as you guys are trying to
make it out
194 why peter why bishop f6 in
particular once we've flipped six i
think now
i can warm up to that i can warm up too
but i think why just go see through c4
now i think so yeah we haven't we
haven't really stopped the main idea
well in this case though yeah the light
doesn't land but the rook will end on c6
like that's a good point queen b6 i
guess here with some queen of two
counter play ideas
queen b6 but i think i play bishop b3 we
never allow queen f2 here we go bish b3
and then we go rook hc1
and yeah it's generally preferable for
white these types of positions but you
do obviously have to watch out for some
e5 before count to play somewhere yeah
rook c1 here i would play queen a5 maybe
instead you have to keep an eye on the
e1 square too but we're getting very
very carried away i'm actually not very
carried away
guess what they're catching they've gone
to to almost the entire line there's
maybe some argument for queen d7 instead
of queen b6 but i like queen b6 better
queen d7 what would the queen be doing
there though just keeping keeping more
options open yeah
just keeping an eye on several squares
yeah rook five five is a useful square
which is why a6 i think is pretty much
never hanging and uh i can go back to b5
if i need b i i like the queen b6 and
aspiring for queen f2 what did he play
he no that that that may not be that may
be our analysis what did you play in
fact did you keep like when you said
when you looked at
one rook c4 rook c4 happened very very
quickly
and just breaking news i've been told
that vichy is drawish yeah i don't know
whether vish is much better and yeah i
don't know which is which is much better
where this is worse
is a little bit worse but vichy is just
up a pawn against viota
yeah
we're not switching but we're not
switching yeah just that
that's what we call a partial
yeah
partial score yeah enough yeah levis lev
is having a very very pleasant pleasant
squeeze hey a4 h4 i love it i love that
uh keeping that a-pawn as a target any
bishop endings were going to be hopeless
for black now
um
but it's time to get the majority going
on the king side or is f5 simply
two weakening peter um
i'm not sure where the counter play
comes i think a 5u you open up yourself
to to additional problems on the king
side as well i think you kind of wait
because the issue for white is in order
to win you either have to win the a5
pawn somehow or you have to play b3
before and both of those things actually
provide black with immediate counterplay
if you play like queen b5 or rook a6 i
will immediately put the queen on f5 and
once that counter play once that queen
activates to to at least some degree uh
you you you start having some some
things to look forward to so yeah left
for now i think is very interested in
improving his position to the maximum
without providing black with a single
hint of of counterplay anywhere h5h4
thrown in i understand that you kind of
eventually you would have to anyway so
why not do it now h3 could move yeah but
black is black is kind of stuck black
currently is very much in the waiting
pattern just
the you you need to see what lev is
doing and then you need to react to it
somehow but yeah i think fabio is in a
lot of trouble here for this is this is
not like it's playing one goal yeah this
is not what you want as an outcome of
this particular line no no and you kind
of trace it back to to the decision to
play b5 so very quickly i don't know if
that was necessary
so queen d2 might provoke bishop to d8
tying black up uh something peter to be
set for re-maneuvering the bishop
towards the d6 yeah i i like sort of
keeping keeping stam on our play queen
to do in particular i think is a very
strong threat right now because if the
bishop leaves the like you would like
maybe to play bishop d8 in many of these
positions but opening yourself up to f3
f4
is something that at least needs to be
sort of properly assessed there's also a
minute and a half down on the clock
fabian is that's not which should be uh
should be quite uh telling quite
important in the you know bishop five
five okay stops queen d2 but
hardcore
uh
we need two with the cheapo
i mean it goes through four it goes to
f4 anyway so i don't think anybody falls
for the cheaper scene we need to floor
with the cheapo
that's a better that's a better way of
doing the same cheapo but we got king g8
g4 g4 is a threat though quincy is a
huge threat now
which is why this is a big threat yeah
which is why he corrected this
is a big threat bishop drop back to f6
yeah you can play a four here but i
don't think you want to actually open
anything yeah yeah he's gone bishop
bishop e1 bishop bishop b1 yeah
oh yeah he's he's saying look i got
rooks i think it's time to play
something like queen a7
i think it's i think it's time i think
we have to kind of go
sami all in here queen a7 rookie six
queen g1 or something like this and
there he goes there's two you go
from yours
it's a d6 hanging it's the time to make
it easy
uh this feels like desperation written
but we were we're not holding those
pawns anyway so we we need to start
generating some kind of counterplay
forward otherwise we're just going to
die a slow and unpleasant death here as
black
it's necessary there is a munch and at
the end yeah
do we go
oh
actually queen e3 is also not and there
is nothing slow or unpleasant duda is
just dead lost
got completely outplayed by by kyrie
oscenco in that game yeah just
completely and utterly outplayed in some
french i think it's and he gets he
basically gets mated now he blundered
something i think he gets mated queen e3
queen g1 i think is going to be met by
rook c2
with the ideas of queen c4 to kind of
consolidate what's going on he's going
through b8 which is a bit of an
a yeah i don't like i i don't like
allowing queen e1 but he wants room
before rook d4 i guess i can sort of
relate to that he he wants both of his
pieces active
at the cost of he doesn't really count
pawns anymore here uh fabi he just needs
all of his pieces to be in play i can
understand uh i suspect it's not enough
against proper play but at least he has
started started asking questions by the
way i'm told that wesley has won his
game very rarely yeah and anton korov
has two wins by move 30
but also not very relevant and
uh prepared yeah
he was happy with the prepared he jumped
on it i think he's happy i think
the position
let's jump to the game guys to the game
because this is important the winner of
this tournament depends on this does
seven wins he didn't find it he did not
find rook takes g7 winning the game duda
is back in it he might have a horrible
position but he's kind of back in it
rook c6 is very clever it covers the
third rank in many positions so the
knight takes e66 rook takes e6 defends
h6 so this could go
any way
still everything to play for and
shivchenko down to 30 seconds yes do
this in tremendous time pressure but so
is kirill now
wow yeah
kirill was it wasn't easy but he was
winning by four by four yeah he no
longer is winning by force he is just
better queen before eight pound a4
yeah it's hanging but the queen before
is a clever reply why is still of course
of course in control here yeah
you can you can do all kinds of things
here i'm kind of thinking rook g3
g3 whatever you want but it's ten
seconds against eight let's do i have to
make a move you gotta make a move
carol going down four rook gt3 plays wow
same move faster was better yeah a3
queen b5 and now put it back yeah that's
i think is correct procedure here that
was very good okay seven yeah with rook
on seven seven
a7
having not won the game by force you are
now kind of struggling to to actually
win it right because right
it's not yeah now the entire thing will
come off along the c file and you know
knight before he very much stabilized
here youngster did yeah the queen
remarkable remarkable absolutely
remarkable wow
oh no no blundering quick yeah kirill
not gonna blunt the queen h4 check there
yeah for
shuffling
they have only how many shuffling
commences yeah well sorry what is the
the the the clock it's four seconds
because it's three there's no way nobody
nobody has anything you have to play
almost instantly let's go i think that
what i think what ends up happening is
that black wins yeah i think he's made
tremendous tremendous power that broke
up to e4
the knight will now come to f4 yeah
should have come to f4 in the previous
move rookie one was a kind of a strange
choice yeah to allow roxy too absolutely
yeah very bizarre stories yeah
rugby one rook only four is a
surprisingly
yeah
no no he just lost the full rope there
fg oh no he kind of resigns wait what
that means the tournament
that ends the tournament that ends the
tournament that ends the tournament and
yeah wow anastasia is going to be very
happy with her prediction i know right
who else can do that
i think i don't think it was just her no
yeah i think there were two i know right
was it me yes it was me
wasn't it
we all forgot
and this she did win this game too by
the way but this
but it's not going to be enough this is
a full rook extra for the local hero in
john
duda he do he's doing it he's doing it
he's got the clock
he's got enough he's got enough he's got
eight seconds it's a rogue it's a rook
wow
yeah
yes it is remarkable scenes yeah
knight bishop summer not coming to f5
that's a nice id i like
oh queen h5
g4 knight coming to f5 everything comes
together and there's the resign
is dominated
yeah he is yes he's just looking looking
at his book and that's it
wins in a spectacular fashion
the final round gives him the victory in
poland
because chefchenko could not finish him
off when the time came to
draw the sword give the final blow to
his opponent he was unable to do so jan
shishof do the first place in poland the
local hero 40 thousand dollars down to
the wire
but what a tournament what an incredible
finish from all of these participants
nice
i just holded my i just been holding my
breath through the last two minutes
peter
yeah that was amazing
that was quite that was quite something
and uh yeah the wind that kirill missed
was not as straightforward as we may
maybe
uh may have sounded like but at the end
he had that extra rook and it was about
the clock but uh
he really kept his poise
this move queen h5 is just great i mean
it's simply grateful you just stop at
all kinds of counter play you're a full
rook opera and every move is a good one
i like it i like i like the technique i
think it was it's it's good but really i
mean everything the phrase should go to
so to think what happened earlier yeah
yeah
fair
fair
and there it is
jk duda
wow
jk jk
nice
and that is
why
thanks to all of our uh
players in this event they really um
well they brought it i mean this was
just that was fun that was that was very
well and that means we got a big tie for
second
with a couple of digit participants i
think fabi and lavon but the wild cards
came in and took their lions share of
the gct points wow wow what an exciting
finish here but i i'm i'm still relevant
let's take a look at what actually
happened where was the mystery as but
what one second as we have the standings
final step final standings yash of duda
he doesn't get any gct points because he
is a wild card in 13. but he would have
gotten 13 otherwise
vichy
also doesn't get any uh because he is
also a wild card player but levon takes
nine favi takes seven it's really not as
many as he wanted but what a comeback
from fabi getting that fourth spot and
wesley you know a little disappointing
but
that goes with the bucharest not bad not
bad and richard oh i think this is a big
disappointment from foreign when you
think about how well he did in the
rapids yeah richard really
faded in at the blitz
but our congratulations to duda that
final game
yeah
he was only really
lost for a very short brief period of
time right out of the opening it was
always slightly worse but then he
misplayed it and yeah the position that
hunter will now show you uh there's a
tactical solution which i'm sure kiril
kept like calculating for 40 seconds and
that's the thing right curl calculated
and calculated and calculated in this
particular position trying to find this
killing blow against the polish star but
wasn't able to find it and it's this one
rook takes g7 check you don't you know
what he wants to play everybody wants to
play this king takes but where's the
follow-up right bishop h6 you see that
the king going anywhere that's not h7
gets made it pretty quickly i don't
think this is very very difficult the
question is what do you play on king h7
now my original intention was queen g5
forcing rook g8 otherwise
there is mate and i wasn't able to fully
find a way but i did see that queen
takes e7 looked like it was good enough
promising yeah this is as far as i got
because if you take on h6 then i can
take on e6 you cannot take on e6 because
check rook c7 game is over let me put
that on the board you go this way i go
checkmate on h3 you go this way i go
checkmate rook c7 and the game just
finishes however um
e6 move earlier yes that you can do that
uh instead of going
uh rook takes g7 you can go knight takes
easy sort of instead of g5 instead of
queen g5 you the more accurate way is to
take on e6 first
this is the best way to do so but the
move queen g5 is good enough right i
think that if you don't find knight e6
and you don't calculate properly rook c3
or whatever sure you can understand that
but queen g5 finishes i think this one
was the more human way to approach the
position and the problem because queen
g5 rook g and queen takes e7 if you
don't play king takes h6 i'm just
position only winning so i don't have to
really understand anything further and
king h696 fails chefchenko did not find
it tournament completely turns on its
head remember chefchenko wins this game
we have a two-way tie for first and we
go into a playoff and instead chachenko
doesn't find it gets outplayed because a
draw would have given us a three-way tie
for first gets outplayed duda wins this
one and wins the tournament what a story
and why does levon go immediately for
the perpetual that is great
i think he misplayed it to to a degree
that he wasn't really safe for him to
continue and really it wasn't it wasn't
even better for him at the end yeah i
think he misplayed it well rick takes d6
so without the move rook takes down
if you play queen e1 here for example
queen e4 21 is the only move if you play
for example queen e4 you have the
problem of rook b4 and your queen
you just gave me a free tempo basically
clear uh queenie one though still keeps
chances alive here in this position so
queen e1
rook b4 i imagine yeah rook v4 and then
you need to start consolidating sorry
sorry now you can take the pawn now
there is no penetration of the queen on
e3 and it just somehow holds you still
also have problems with e5 falling with
check so you have to go queen d4 to try
to get some perpetuals and the engine is
saying there are no perpetuals you can
play queen c1 or rook d8 but in a blitz
game i think this still can be anybody's
game two pawns two it's two pawns i get
it but you know there's still counter
play and i think he must have missed the
move queen e3 entirely because once you
get
what you don't let the queen jump to e3
if you see it coming from afar and then
he was forced to give her perpetual yeah
putting him out of the contention
because duda won a full point and he
needed to keep up
and there you have it
[Laughter]
but let's
let's jump to warsaw for the closing
ceremonies and the crowning of a
champion
after five days of thrilling chess
action we are finally ready to crown a
champion i am joined here in the studio
by michael kadarkovsky the executive
director of the grand chess tour adam
lamentovich from ceo of superbad poland
and jan shishtav duda michael i'm going
to give you the first word
uh thank you christian
indeed there were five exciting days
with three days of rapid than tiger of
madras
former world champion
vichyanan took first place but then two
exciting
days when
uh young
duda
was able to overcome
uh deficits and points and in the last
round and grab
the win
for first
ever grandchild's tour
here in warsaw poland and i would like
to congratulate of course
uh the winner on one end on another end
i want to thank super bad foundation and
super bad poland for hosting this event
and sponsoring this event
and uh we look forward to see
uh in third
lag
in zagreb even more exciting games that
we have seen here in warsaw
and i would like to pass
the microphone to
uh super bet poland ceo
adam lamentage
thank you michael it's great to be here
a lot of emotions at the end so
still excited and
thank you very much
uniting minds
it was a great experience for us here in
poland
lots of people lots of spectators and
first of all
top chess players of the world
and i as polish national i couldn't hope
for better ending
so i really congratulate janek for for
this result it's a great pleasure uh to
be here with you and
to be the host of this event and thank
you very much to granchester for the
trust to host it for the first time in
poland please present the trophy to the
winner
it's very beautiful
jan shishtav a crazy day please describe
to us our feelings right now
yeah i'm extremely happy of course to
win this event
um
i can say that i'm kind of i mean i'm
recognized as kind of this specialist
but
i must confess that
it was extremely difficult i feel
extremely difficult um
opponents
and
yeah i'm very happy actually to win it
because it was of course very nervous
till the very end
and
yeah it's very
very it's very special
i mean it's very nice that uh i have one
here in warsaw in poland
um
it has a special value to me
tell us what does it mean to win in
front of your home crowd
yeah it feels very nice and
i guess i'm about to see
what it's
what is coming actually
you are one and a half points behind the
leader going into today's rounds what
was the strategy going into these rounds
um
yeah i was very focused uh against my i
mean against vichy i thought it's um
like very important actually to win
against him because uh he was the leader
at the time
and also i mean i didn't uh hadn't
managed actually to beat him in this
game like in my life so that was of
course a very good start
also winning against wesley was kind of
unexpected because
i lost two game against him before and i
managed now to win with black um yeah
but there are always
there are always ups and downs um
yeah i
was very disappointed actually when i
lost to publiano because
i i just blundered in a very nice
position and almost risk-free
and also my loss against kurobov was
very heartbreaking actually because i
mean he's of course a very strong and
creative player
but
yeah but i
got to have a very good score against
him actually
i think i won like five plus games which
play against each other
so
yeah that was heartbreaking but then i
managed actually to um to win i mean the
last the last game was kind of funny
actually i mean probably a blunders even
rooted g7 at some point uh yeah it was
very you know like nervous game of
course and
uh yeah but it was fun of course and um
i'm very satisfied with my playing
overall an incredible performance any
final words for your fans here in poland
as well as all over the world yeah i
would like to thank everyone who is
rooting for me um yeah i said i'm very
i'm very pleased to win here in poland
and uh
yeah i have had like a lot of support
here and there are many people so thanks
to to everybody and also to my family
and
friends and coaches and everyone who
helped me achieving this success
ladies and gentlemen the champion of the
2022 superbad rapid m blitz yan shishtov
duda
very nicely done by
christian and we we want to be the one
to applaud that uh very very solid i'm
seeing there and yeah
a lot of things
have to go to to christian and honest
anastasia who provided
a lot of
insight from uh from
warsaw and from bucharest prior to that
yes always a pleasure to work with you
both
and after
that tournament uh let's just take a
look at the gt
gct standings after poland inclusive uh
peter please do the honor uh levon
iranian now leading the the gcd
standings obviously the 13 points that
got taken off
out of
not helping our general standings but
yeah levon is on top there with uh 1950
points and almost a
six-figure number in uh prize money
wesley in second uh fabian third mvl uh
in fourth with mvl did not unveil is
only really coming off one event one of
these he has an event in hand compared
to our top three there
in the table
uh and the the rest uh
not really shining that much apologies
uh richard had a poor tournament in
bucharest and
it looked like he might really sort of
ride the ship here but he had a very
very poor showing in blitz and it didn't
really happen and then as we go to the
next stops we've got uh zagreb where
juan magnus carlson might have something
to say about that gct tour distribution
absolutely that will be uh you know hot
on the heels of the cannabis tournament
so it will be uh there will be an
additional an additional narrative
because we will know who is who gets to
play magnus or perhaps
not magnus we obviously
don't don't know exactly exactly what
will happen there but that's the topic
for another day i guess
ect finishes here in st louis and peter
yeah and then we get the two tournaments
uh ending the season as usual in st
louis first rapid and blitz in the last
week of august and then immediately
after that the sink filled cup
and here we have it once more the final
final firing final standing six wild
cards four tour participants and like
you were saying the wild cards and
youngsters of the occupying the top top
top top top top top 13 points indeed uh
welcome back vishy we miss you that was
really
you gave us so many thrills and when
vichy is on his game doesn't he look
smooth alejandro yeah
it's just a
a tiny bit heartbreaking in this
tournament right right he starts five
out of five finishes the rapids so
strongly right and just couldn't
couldn't really get through the finish
line and win this gct but
duda i mean he just he knew how
important the first round today was
beating vichy was such a crucial part of
the day just set the tone in so many
ways
giving duda that hope that he can catch
up to vichy vishy falling down from a
one and a half point lead going into the
last day a bit heartbreaking for vichy
fans but at the end of the day he did
finish second at some point he was
fourth in the standings today so he did
come back from that and we're here we
see our predictions congratulations to
you and anastasia you got it right when
we know you know yes sir it's just part
of being here it's so disappointing
i am so disappointed with far as an
influencer you know
he dragged me into this yes but uh
christian was right up there uh as well
peter i want again to say to you and
alejandro how much fun it was really we
have to do it again i don't know where i
don't know when i'll look forward to it
very much so yeah thanks uh thanks to
everybody for uh inviting me here it's
been a pleasure and yeah thanks for
watching uh
and just to remind everybody we will
have the candidates coverage
coming up next here from st louis june
17th through july 5th full coverage uh
with our today in chess show again thank
you everybody for joining us i hope you
had as much fun as we all did and until
next time bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited